Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. the Tudor's transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转向了帝国，都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。你知道吗？Hive 也经历了自己的变革。大家都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化成了更伟大的事物。能帮你用清洁能源为家庭供电的太阳能电池板，以及能从空气中汲取热量的热泵。
EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs,
还有在你睡觉时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电桩。所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家庭的能力，从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消费到贡献。所以，历史上下一个伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，它可能就发生在你的家里。一场没有断头台的静默革命。Hive。了解你的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive 应用程序兼容选定的热泵。本期节目由 SAP 赞助。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本，
connect with new suppliers and manage payroll, even when your business is being pulled in different directions, to deliver a quality product at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at sap.com slash uncertainty. When you wish upon a star makes no difference who you are. Anything your heart desires will come to you.
与新供应商建立联系并管理工资单，即使在您的业务被拉向不同方向时，也能以合理的价格提供优质产品，同时支付员工应得的报酬，让您的业务保持从容不迫。在 sap.com/uncertainty 了解更多信息。当你向星星许愿时，无论你是谁，只要你心中渴望，一切都会实现。
if your heart is in your dream no request is too extreme when you wish upon a star as dreamers do so if you're still with us that was when you wish upon a star which is of course the official company anthem of Disney
如果你的心在你的梦想中，没有请求是太极端的。当你像梦想家那样向星星许愿时。所以，如果你还在听，刚才那首歌是《当你向星星许愿时》，当然，这是迪士尼的官方公司主题曲。
now Disney which effectively began as a young man tinkering, basically pursuing a hobby, is now a business worth $200 billion. Everybody knows the name of Disney. It's the owner of Star Wars franchise, of Marvel, of course of theme parks everywhere on the planet, most famously Disneyland and Disney World in America. It is an organization that has an almost unparalleled grip
现在，迪士尼最初实际上是一个年轻人捣鼓出来的，基本上是追求一种爱好，现在却是一家价值 2000 亿美元的企业。每个人都知道迪士尼这个名字。它是星球大战系列、漫威的拥有者，当然还有遍布全球的主题公园，最著名的是美国的迪士尼乐园和迪士尼世界。这是一个在某种程度上拥有无与伦比的影响力的组织，
on the world's imagination, particularly of children, which is when the imagination is most formative. Now, Tom, you were very keen to kick off with this song, partly because you were desperate to do those vocals because you love any opportunity to sing on the show for some reason, but also I think because the song captures something of the nostalgia and the sentimentality that is at the core of Disney.
对世界想象力的掌控，尤其是对儿童的想象力，因为那是想象力最容易形成的时期。汤姆，你非常热衷于以这首歌开场，部分原因是你非常渴望演唱那段歌词，因为出于某种原因，你喜欢在节目中唱歌的任何机会，但我认为也是因为这首歌捕捉到了迪士尼核心的那种怀旧和感伤。
I don't mean those things pejoratively because, of course, they're tremendously appealing for a lot of people, aren't they? Yeah, it's the great anthem of Disney, and it's a reminder as well that Disney has a, its origins in the kind of the Golden Age of Hollywood, but more specifically, it's a reminder of the company's origin in the dreams and the distinctive personality of the man that you just mentioned. The filmmaker who founded Disney, gave it his name, the figure who probably more than any other, I would say, embodies American culture in the 20th century, and that is, of course, Walt
我并不是贬义地指这些东西，因为当然，它们对很多人来说非常有吸引力，不是吗？是的，这是迪士尼的伟大赞歌，它也提醒我们，迪士尼起源于好莱坞的黄金时代，但更具体地说，它提醒我们这家公司起源于你刚才提到的那个人的梦想和独特的个性。那位创立了迪士尼并以其名字命名的电影制作人，那个我可以说比任何其他人都更能体现 20 世纪美国文化的人物，当然就是华特·迪士尼。
Disney. Oh, definitely. He's one of the most important cultural figures globally of the 20th century, I would say. Yeah, absolutely. And so the lyrics of when you wish upon a star, which you read rather than sang, but you read it very beautifully, anything your heart desires will come to you. I mean, that may seem very schmaltzy to people, but I would argue that it is up there with rock around the clock, so the Bill Haley classic that really kind of ushered in rock and roll as a song that marks a key turning point in the culture of 20th century America. I think anybody who's tempted to listen to this show and say, oh, Disney, why are they doing Disney? It's just a thing for children.
哦，绝对是。我认为他是 20 世纪全球最重要的文化人物之一。是的，绝对是。所以《当你向星星许愿时》的歌词，你读了而不是唱了，但你读得非常优美，“只要你心中渴望，一切都会实现”。我的意思是，这对人们来说可能看起来非常矫情，但我会说它与比尔·哈利的经典之作《围绕时钟摇滚》（Rock Around the Clock）不相上下，那首歌真正开启了摇滚乐时代，是 20 世纪美国文化的一个关键转折点。我认为任何想听这个节目并说“哦，迪士尼，他们为什么要讲迪士尼？那只是给孩子看的东西”的人，
I think completely misses the impact that Disney has had in shaping the imaginations and therefore the cultural political choices of hundreds of millions of people ever since Disney really broke through in the, what, the 1930s, I suppose. Yeah, and that's that song. I mean, it's the first song in history to have been sung by a talking insect, for instance. So that's definitely a first. I mean, obviously, it's not literally sung by a talking insect. It was sung by an actor called Cliff Edwards. And he was ventriloquizing a cartoon character called Jiminy Cricket in a film called Pinocchio. And I'm sure lots of people will have seen Pinocchio, but those who haven't.
我认为完全忽略了迪士尼在塑造数亿人的想象力，进而塑造他们的文化和政治选择方面所产生的影响，自从迪士尼在 20 世纪 30 年代真正取得突破以来，我想是这样。是的，就是那首歌。我的意思是，这是历史上第一首由会说话的昆虫演唱的歌曲，例如。所以这绝对是第一次。我的意思是，显然，它并不是真的由一只会说话的昆虫演唱的。它是由一位名叫克里夫·爱德华兹的演员演唱的。他在一部名为《木偶奇遇记》的电影中为卡通人物吉米尼蟋蟀配音。我相信很多人都看过《木偶奇遇记》，但那些没看过的人，
Pinocchio is a puppet, a puppet of a boy who's carved by a toy maker called Geppetto. And Geppetto, as he's going to sleep, wishes upon a star, wishes that this puppet he's made will come to life. And sure enough, a blue fairy appears and brings Pinocchio to life. And Jiminy is the cricket that's appointed by the Blue Fairy to serve Pinocchio as his conscience. And over the course of the film, they have all kinds of adventures. So Pinocchio, he ends up basically enslaved to a villainous puppeteer who locks them up in a cage. They visit Pleasure Island. Dominant, you love a pleasure island. It's a very sinister theme park where Pinocchio narrowly avoids being turned into a donkey and they get swallowed up by a whale. And I think we are so used to animation bringing
匹诺曹是一个木偶，一个由名叫杰佩托的玩具匠雕刻的男孩木偶。杰佩托在睡觉时向星星许愿，希望他制作的这个木偶能活过来。果然，一位蓝仙女出现了，让匹诺曹活了过来。吉米尼是蓝仙女指派给匹诺曹担任他良心的蟋蟀。在电影的过程中，他们经历了各种各样的冒险。所以匹诺曹，他最终基本上被一个邪恶的木偶师奴役，把他锁在笼子里。他们参观了快乐岛。多米尼克，你喜欢快乐岛。那是一个非常阴险的主题公园，匹诺曹险些被变成驴子，他们还被鲸鱼吞了下去。我认为我们已经习惯了动画将
stories like this to life today that it can actually be incredibly hard to recapture the sense of stupefaction of absolute wonder that greeted a film like Pinocchio. I mean, nothing, you know, just jaw-dropping for people to see this. Yeah. And Disney, Walt Disney, even if he'd never made a single theme bark, or indeed if he'd done nothing, after the Second World War at all, if he'd been knocked down by a bus or something, he would still have a very high place in the kind of cultural annals of the last century because he more than anybody is the person who establishes animation as a mass media art form, isn't he?
今天这样的故事带入生活，以至于实际上可能很难重现那种迎接像《木偶奇遇记》这样的电影时的那种目瞪口呆、绝对惊奇的感觉。我的意思是，没什么，你知道，人们看到这个简直惊掉下巴。是的。而且华特·迪士尼，即使他从未建造过任何主题公园，或者如果他在二战后什么都没做，如果他被公共汽车撞倒之类的，他在上个世纪的文化史册中仍然会占有很高的地位，因为他比任何人都更是一个将动画确立为大众媒体艺术形式的人，不是吗？
Yeah, so basically his career up to Pinocchio is a series of massive cultural landmarks. So, 1928, you have Steamboat Willie or Rat on a Boat, as Theo calls it, which introduces Mickey Mouse to a mass audience. And it's crucial in the history of animation and indeed a film, because it's the first cartoon with fully synchronized sound, sound that is coming directly from the characters, so from Mickey and so on. And it's kind of, it's the jazz singer of animation, really. It's the one that fuses animation and audio. Then five years later, 1933, you have a cartoon called Three Little Pigs. And I mean, again, kind of amazing innovations in that. So the colour, perhaps particularly, very vibrant, very true to life.
是的，所以基本上他到《木偶奇遇记》之前的职业生涯是一系列巨大的文化里程碑。所以，1928 年，你有《威利号汽船》或西奥所说的“船上的老鼠”，它将米老鼠介绍给了大众观众。这在动画史乃至电影史上都是至关重要的，因为它是第一部拥有完全同步声音的卡通片，声音直接来自角色，也就是来自米奇等等。它实际上是动画界的《爵士歌手》。它是将动画和音频融合在一起的那一部。然后五年后，1933 年，你有一部名为《三只小猪》的卡通片。我的意思是，再次，其中有令人惊叹的创新。所以色彩，也许特别地，非常鲜艳，非常逼真。
Yeah, people's minds are absolutely blown by this. They've never seen anything like it. But also the characterisation, the fact that these are animated characters who are not just kind of tools for a gag or something. They seem to have distinct personalities, you know, the three little pigs, they will have their various characteristics. And, of course, anticipating when you wish upon a star, it has a classic theme song, who's afraid of the big bad wolf
是的，人们的思维完全被这个震撼了。他们从未见过这样的东西。但还有角色塑造，事实上这些是动画角色，而不仅仅是某种噱头或什么的工具。他们似乎有独特的个性，你知道，三只小猪，他们都有各自的特征。当然，预示着《当你向星星许愿时》，它有一首经典的主题曲，“谁怕大灰狼”
and this absolutely bores itself into the consciousness of Depression era America and to quote Neil Gabler whose definitive biography of Disney kind of drawing on all kinds of previously untapped sources by biographers we're going to be referring to a lot over the course of this episode
这绝对钻进了大萧条时期美国的意识中，引用尼尔·加布勒的话，他的迪士尼权威传记借鉴了传记作者以前未曾利用的各种来源，我们将在本期节目中多次提到
he describes that song as it indisputably became the nation's new anthem its cheerful whoop hurled in the face of hard times Yeah, and then you've got, I mean, the biggest film, I would argue Disney's supreme cinematic achievement is Snow White. That's 1937, I think. And that's the first full length animated feature, isn't it? And up to that point, the idea of doing animated feature at all just seemed, A, impossible and almost mind-boggling as sort of, it would be such an extraordinary enterprise, so time-consuming, so expensive, that it had never occurred to anybody to do it. Yeah, and so the tradition is that people are so gobsmacked when they learn what Disney's planning, that they call it Disney's folly. But it's all very geppetto. Disney's clearly wished upon a star, because when it's released, it's a massive global hit.
他将那首歌描述为它无可争议地成为了国家的新国歌，它那欢快的欢呼声是对抗艰难时期的呐喊。是的，然后你有了，我的意思是，最大的电影，我会说迪士尼最伟大的电影成就，是《白雪公主》。我想那是 1937 年。那是第一部全长动画长片，不是吗？在那之前，制作动画长片的想法本身似乎，A，是不可能的，几乎令人难以置信，这会是一项如此非凡的事业，如此耗时，如此昂贵，以至于从来没有人想到要去做它。是的，所以传统是，当人们得知迪士尼的计划时，他们感到非常震惊，以至于他们称之为“迪士尼的愚行”。但这一切都非常像杰佩托。迪士尼显然向星星许愿了，因为当它上映时，它是一个巨大的全球热门。
In fact, I mean, at one point, I was astonished to read this. It was the most successful sound film ever released. And it's a huge box office hit then, but it's also a critical hit. So in 1944, in a war-torn Britain, the great British film director Michael Powell, as in Powell and Pressburger, sums up why Snow White and Seven Dwarfs is a cultural landmark. So he said in that film, Disney abolished naturalism, established stylistic settings and backgrounds, controlled his design of color and sound, a feat not yet in the power of any other producer, and held audiences enraptured all over the world.
事实上，我的意思是，有一次，我读到这个感到非常惊讶。它是当时有史以来最成功的有声电影。它不仅在当时是巨大的票房热门，而且也是评论界的成功。所以 1944 年，在饱受战争蹂躏的英国，伟大的英国电影导演迈克尔·鲍威尔（鲍威尔与普雷斯伯格组合中的一员）总结了为什么《白雪公主与七个小矮人》是一个文化里程碑。他说在那部电影中，迪士尼废除了自然主义，建立了风格化的场景和背景，控制了他的色彩和声音设计，这是一项其他任何制片人尚未具备的壮举，并让全世界的观众着迷。
So you can see there that it's obviously absolutely massively influential on animation, but also on other films as well. I mean, you can see it in Powell and Pressburger's films. You look at the other films of 1937 and 1938. I'm just looking at the list now. Saratoga, Maytime, The Good Earth, 1938, Boys Town, Alexander's Ragtime Band, Test Pilot.
所以你可以看到，它显然对动画产生了巨大的影响，但也对其他电影产生了影响。我的意思是，你可以在鲍威尔和普雷斯伯格的电影中看到它。你看看 1937 年和 1938 年的其他电影。我正在看名单。1938 年的《萨拉托加》、《五月时光》、《大地》、《男孩城》、《亚历山大的拉格泰姆乐队》、《试飞员》。
You can't take it with you, sweethearts. Nobody watches those films. Nobody's even heard of most of those films. I guess the vast majority. Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs. Even if you've never seen it, you're familiar. You've still got it in your head. Yeah, it's absolutely living in your head.
《浮生若梦》、《甜心》。没人看那些电影。大多数人甚至没听说过那些电影。我猜绝大多数。只有《白雪公主与七个小矮人》。即使你没看过，你也熟悉。它仍然在你的脑海里。是的，它绝对活在你的脑海里。
It's a massive success. and Pinocchio is the follow-up. It's the second feature-length film that Disney makes. And I guess it kind of sets, you know, the seal on his reputation as the most innovative filmmaker of the age. And so when you wish upon a star, which sounds very, very syrupy to us, it kind of serves as the anthem for everything that makes him cutting edge. I mean, and that's the amazing thing about it. You know, it goes on to win the Oscar for Best Film in 1941. It's really important to emphasize how mad that is, an animated. character, an animated insect winning an Oscar. I think again and again, when you look at Disney, you've got to think what is it like for people to listen or to see this for the first time? And I think that
这是一个巨大的成功，而《木偶奇遇记》是后续作品。这是迪士尼制作的第二部动画长片。我想它在某种程度上为他作为那个时代最具创新性的电影制作人的声誉盖棺定论了。所以当《当你向星星许愿时》响起，这对我们来说听起来非常非常甜腻，它在某种程度上成为了让他处于领先地位的一切的赞歌。我的意思是，这就是它令人惊奇的地方。你知道，它在 1941 年获得了奥斯卡最佳电影奖。强调这一点有多疯狂真的很重要，一个动画角色，一个动画昆虫赢得了奥斯卡。我想一次又一次，当你审视迪士尼时，你必须思考人们第一次听到或看到这个是什么感觉？我认为
one of the issues with getting a proper sense of Disney's cultural importance is that he's really the first great example of, you know, what becomes a classic 20th century American phenomenon. He's an innovator whose influence is so profound that today you tend to take it for granted. So
正确理解迪士尼的文化重要性的问题之一是，他确实是 20 世纪经典美国现象的第一个伟大例子。他是一位创新者，其影响力如此深远，以至于今天你往往认为这是理所当然的。所以
on the cultural level, you know, he's massive innovator. We've been describing that. He's been, he develops, he shapes an entire new art form. And I guess that the closest parallel in the second half of the 20th century to that would be Elvis, you know, who in a similar way makes a kind of an emergent genre his own and then broadcast it to the world. But it's Disney who gets there first. So to quote Neil Gabler again, it's Disney who helped establish American popular culture as the dominant culture in the world. Well, in the next episode, we'll be describing Nikita Khristroff and his wife and how they loved Disney films. Nikita Khrushchev's wife had first seen them in the 1940s.
在文化层面上，你知道，他是巨大的创新者。我们一直在描述这一点。他开发、塑造了一种全新的艺术形式。我想 20 世纪下半叶与之最接近的平行人物会是猫王，你知道，他以类似的方式使一种新兴流派成为他自己的，然后将其传播给世界。但迪士尼是第一个做到这一点的人。所以再次引用尼尔·加布勒的话，是迪士尼帮助确立了美国流行文化作为世界上主导文化的地位。好吧，在下一集中，我们将描述尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫和他的妻子，以及他们是如何喜欢迪士尼电影的。尼基塔·赫鲁晓夫的妻子在 20 世纪 40 年代第一次看到它们。
And the fact that somebody in the Soviet Union has fallen in love with Disney's vision, a very American vision, gives you some sense of the kind of global power that it had even then. But I think part of what Khrushchev very reluctantly has fallen in love with, it's not just the cultural kind of resonance of Disney. it's also the technological one. So again and again, when I was reading Gabler's biography, I was reminded not just of Elvis or someone like that, a kind of cultural innovator, but of Steve Jobs, who was a great technological innovator.
事实上，苏联有人爱上了迪士尼的愿景，一种非常美国的愿景，让你感受到即使在当时它所拥有的那种全球力量。但我认为赫鲁晓夫非常不情愿地爱上的部分，不仅仅是迪士尼的文化共鸣。它也是技术上的共鸣。所以一次又一次，当我阅读加布勒的传记时，我不仅想起了猫王或类似的人，那种文化创新者，还想起了史蒂夫·乔布斯，他是一位伟大的技术创新者。
So if you think of Disney and Steve Jobs, both of them are complete perfectionists, absolutely kind of obsessed by the opportunities that they've been given by a technology that's still in its infancy. Both of them are very Californian figures, and both of them start off, kind of tinkering, in Steve Jobs' case, famously in a shed. But Disney, you know, his early
所以如果你想到迪士尼和史蒂夫·乔布斯，他们两人都是完美的完美主义者，绝对被一种仍处于起步阶段的技术所提供的机会所吸引。他们两人都是非常加利福尼亚的人物，而且他们两人都是从捣鼓开始的，在史蒂夫·乔布斯的例子中，著名地是在一个棚子里。但迪士尼，你知道，他早期的
animations are made in garages and so on. And both of them end up becoming the public face of, you know, a vast and wealthy company. And I would say that in the 21st century, Apple and Disney, they're globe-spanning beer moths, who for most people across the world are part of the public face of America. Totally. Actually, Steve Jobs sent it up on the board of Disney, didn't he? after he sold Pixar to Disney. So it's a nice comparison. All right. But Walt Disney's own career.
动画是在车库里制作的等等。他们两人最终都成为了一个庞大而富有公司的公众形象。我想在 21 世纪，苹果和迪士尼，它们是跨越全球的庞然大物，对于世界各地的大多数人来说，它们是美国公众形象的一部分。完全正确。实际上，史蒂夫·乔布斯进入了迪士尼的董事会，不是吗？在他把皮克斯卖给迪士尼之后。所以这是一个很好的比较。好吧。但华特·迪士尼自己的职业生涯。
He's born in December 1901. And in some ways, he's a 19th, I think he's a quite 19th century figure. You know, many years ago I wrote about Samuel Smiles, the great self-help guru of their Victorian period, who wrote a book called The Lives of the Engineers. And he was, Samuel Smiles was fascinated by all these people who, you know, they started kind of tinkering the James Watt and Matthew Bolton and kind of steam engine people and people like that. And Walt Disney always feels to me like one of those kinds of figures. There is something very backward looking about to, I think, very nostalgic. He's somebody who would completely
他出生于 1901 年 12 月。在某些方面，我认为他是一个相当 19 世纪的人物。你知道，多年前我写过关于塞缪尔·斯迈尔斯的文章，他是维多利亚时代伟大的自助大师，他写了一本名为《工程师传》的书。他，塞缪尔·斯迈尔斯对所有这些开始捣鼓的人着迷，詹姆斯·瓦特和马修·博尔顿以及蒸汽机之类的人。华特·迪士尼给我的感觉总是像那些人物之一。我认为他身上有一些非常向后看的东西，非常怀旧。他是一个完全
have been at home 20 or 30 years earlier. I think a classically American version of that. And actually, if you look at his ancestry, it's like, it's always kind of comically, it contains within it so many different threads of history. So, I mean, amazingly, I wasn't expecting to bring up the Norman Conquest in an episode on Walt Disney, but Disney claimed, I gather that genealogists say it's not a completely mad idea, that he was descended from a Norman who came over from the Norman town of Izni. So Disney. So in that case, his forebears, you know, were Norman aristocrats. But they seem to have migrated from England to Ireland and then from Ireland in 1834 to the New World. And Disney's grandfather, his guy called
会在 20 或 30 年前感到宾至如归的人。我认为这是一个典型的美国版本。实际上，如果你看他的祖先，就像，它总是相当滑稽地，其中包含了许多不同的历史线索。所以，我的意思是，令人惊讶的是，我没想到会在关于华特·迪士尼的一集中提到诺曼征服，但迪士尼声称，我收集到家谱学家说这不是一个完全疯狂的想法，他是从诺曼城镇伊兹尼（Izni）过来的诺曼人的后裔。所以迪士尼。所以在那情况下，他的祖先，你知道，是诺曼贵族。但他们似乎从英格兰迁移到了爱尔兰，然后从爱尔兰在 1834 年迁移到了新世界。而迪士尼的祖父，他的一个家伙叫
a brilliant name of Keppel, Keppel Disney. I mean, basically he engages in everything you would expect a prospector in, you know, 90th century America to do. So he works as a farmer. He works as a gold prospector. He drills for oil. None of these ventures really pays off for him. He's a bit of a drifter. He ends up in Florida, and there his son, Elias, meets a 16-year-old girl called Flora. And Flora again, brilliant. She's the kind of living embodiment of American mythology. So she's the descendant of a pioneer who traveled to America in 1636. So she's almost within touching distance of the pilgrim fathers. And Elias and Flora marry on Neos Day, 1888 in Florida.
一个绝妙的名字叫凯佩尔，凯佩尔·迪士尼。我的意思是，基本上他从事了你期望 19 世纪美国的探矿者所做的一切。所以他做农民。他做黄金探矿者。他钻探石油。这些冒险都没有真正为他带来回报。他有点漂泊不定。他最终到了佛罗里达，在那里他的儿子埃利亚斯遇到了一个名叫弗洛拉的 16 岁女孩。而弗洛拉再次，绝妙。她是美国神话的活生生的化身。所以她是 1636 年前往美国的先驱的后裔。所以她几乎触手可及清教徒先辈。埃利亚斯和弗洛拉于 1888 年元旦在佛罗里达结婚。
But Elias is like his dad. He is never a man for staying in one place. And in 1890, he upsticks. He moves from Florida. And he and his wife head off to Chicago. And in Chicago, he works as a carpenter. And it is in Chicago in the dead of winter. in late 1901 that Walt Disney is born.
但埃利亚斯就像他的父亲。他从来不是一个在一个地方呆着的人。在 1890 年，他搬走了。他从佛罗里达搬走。他和他的妻子前往芝加哥。在芝加哥，他做木匠。正是在芝加哥的严冬，在 1901 年底，华特·迪士尼出生了。
Oh, that was nice. So his childhood is quite Dickensian, isn't it? Because his father is pretty tough. Neil Gabler says he's this sort of hard, driven, devout. He worked hard, lived modestly and worshipped devoutly. But he's also moving around the whole time because he never really settles, never makes a success of anything. The most obvious place where they live is in Missouri, small-town Missouri, a place that becomes
哦，那很好。所以他的童年相当狄更斯式，不是吗？因为他的父亲相当强硬。尼尔·加布勒说他是一种坚硬、被驱动、虔诚的人。他努力工作，生活简朴，虔诚地崇拜。但他也是一直在搬家，因为他从来没有真正安定下来，从来没有在任何事情上取得成功。他们居住的最明显的地方是在密苏里州，密苏里州的一个小镇，一个成为
absolutely embedded in Walt Disney's imagination, and you could argue in the world's imagination, because it's the inspiration for the main street that you find in Disney's parks. And this is a place called Marcelline in Missouri. If anyone's seen or heard the Philip Glass opera about Walt Disney, it's all about him trying to get back to Marcelline and his memories of Marcelline. And he has this sort of romantic fantasy, doesn't he? of small town America. But for Elias, it's actually pretty tough because he's trying to scratch a living as a farmer and he fails. So in 1911, he moves to Kansas City and he buys a
绝对嵌入华特·迪士尼想象力的地方，你可以说在世界的想象力中，因为它是你在迪士尼公园里发现的主街的灵感来源。这是一个叫马塞琳的地方，在密苏里州。如果有人看过或听过关于华特·迪士尼的菲利普·格拉斯歌剧，它全是关于他试图回到马塞琳以及他对马塞琳的记忆。他有这种浪漫的幻想，不是吗？关于美国小镇。但对于埃利亚斯来说，这实际上相当艰难，因为他试图作为一个农民勉强维持生计，但他失败了。所以 1911 年，他搬到了堪萨斯城，他买了一个
newspaper delivery route, as Americans would put it, a route. And essentially this means, you know, he has to get up very early in the morning and shove newspapers through people's letter boxes. And he gets Walt and his elder brother, Roy, to help him. And Walt by this point is nine years old. So he's having to get up at 4.30, you know, even when it's winter, absolutely freezing in Kansas City in the dead of winter, you know, wading through thick snow drifts. And unsurprisingly, I mean, it affects his schoolwork. He's too often too tired to concentrate. So that is quite Dickensian. I think there is an element of the blacking factory about that. And it doesn't go brilliantly well. But the whole time, Elias has been saving up money.
报纸投递路线，正如美国人所说的那样，一条路线。本质上这意味着，你知道，他必须在清晨起床，把报纸塞进人们的信箱。他让华特和他的哥哥罗伊帮他。华特此时九岁。所以他不得不 4:30 起床，你知道，即使在冬天，在堪萨斯城的严冬里绝对冷得要命，你知道，在厚厚的积雪中跋涉。不出所料，我的意思是，这影响了他的学业。他太累了，无法集中注意力。所以这相当狄更斯式。我认为其中有黑鞋油工厂的成分。而且进展并不顺利。但整个过程中，埃利亚斯一直在存钱。
And in 1917, he moves back to Chicago and he invests his savings in a jelly factory. Do Americans call it jello? I think they do, don't they? I think when they call it jelly, they're talking about jam. But when they're talking about jello, they're talking about jelly. Is it jello or is it, is it jelly or jam? It's jello. Come on, make your minds up, Americans. Sort yourselves out.
在 1917 年，他搬回了芝加哥，他把积蓄投资在了一家果冻工厂。美国人称之为 Jello 吗？我想他们是这样，不是吗？我想当他们称之为果冻（jelly）时，他们指的是果酱。但当他们谈论 Jello 时，他们指的是果冻。是 Jello 还是，是果冻还是果酱？是 Jello。得了吧，下定决心吧，美国人。整理好你们自己。
But it's not all grim, right? It's not all. So there is actual genuine jelly amid the custard. I don't know where I'm going with that metaphor. Because there's light as well as dark in Disney's childhood. Well, yeah. So Elias is a very hard man. We said that.
但这并不全是阴暗的，对吧？这并不全是。所以卡仕达酱中确实有真正的果冻。我不知道我用那个隐喻要表达什么。因为迪士尼的童年里既有光明也有黑暗。好吧，是的。所以埃利亚斯是一个非常强硬的人。我们说过这一点。
But his mother, Flora, is very gentle, very nurturing. And the key role that she plays in Walt's development is that she encourages him with his great obsession, which has become drawing and specifically cartoons. And reading about Walt as a child, you get the sense of him as being simultaneously dreamy and obsessional. And I guess that those are characteristics that, you know, will accompany him throughout his life. And there's a famous Tom Sawyer style episode where Walt draws cartoons in creosote all over a white fence. and even Flora is cross with him about that. But in general, she's very supportive. And another very supportive figure in the family is his elder brother Roy,
但他的母亲弗洛拉非常温柔，非常善于培养。她在华特成长过程中扮演的关键角色是，她鼓励他追求他伟大的痴迷，这已经变成了绘画，特别是卡通。阅读关于华特童年的资料，你会感觉到他同时既爱做梦又爱钻牛角尖。我想这些特征，你知道，将伴随他一生。有一个著名的汤姆·索亚式的插曲，华特用杂酚油在白栅栏上画卡通，甚至弗洛拉也为此对他生气。但总的来说，她非常支持。家庭中另一个非常支持的人物是他的哥哥罗伊，
who is very practical, very hard-headed. He gets a job in a bank that enables him to kind of buy Walt toys that otherwise Walt wouldn't have. And I think he, in a way, is kind of, he's kind of more of a father figure, perhaps even than Elias is. You know, he's always looking out for Walt. So there is security amid all the kind of the uncertainty, the constant moving. And I think also the other thing that the constant moving does is that it does give him a very precocious feel for America.
他非常务实，非常精明。他在银行找到了一份工作，使他能够为华特购买华特否则买不起的玩具。我认为他，在某种程度上，他更像是一个父亲形象，甚至比埃利亚斯更像。你知道，他总是照顾华特。所以即使在所有的不确定性、不断的搬迁中也有安全感。而且我认为不断的搬迁所做的另一件事是，它确实给了他对美国一种非常早熟的感觉。
You've mentioned how Marcelline will kind of haunt his imagining. But I think also he, he's been Kansas City, he's been to Chicago, he has a sense of what makes America tick. And that again will be kind of crucial to his ability to give form to the fantasies and dreams. of America. Yeah. He's, uh, Kansas City has given him a sense of the big city, but he's also got a sense of the small town. He's got a sense of the landscapes.
你提到了马塞琳将如何困扰他的想象。但我认为他也，他去过堪萨斯城，他去过芝加哥，他有一种对美国运作方式的感觉。而这再次将对他的能力至关重要，即赋予美国的幻想和梦想以形式。是的。他，呃，堪萨斯城给了他一种大城市的感觉，但他也有小城镇的感觉。他有一种对景观的感觉。
He's been on trains. You know, all of that kind of world, that Midwestern world is kind of, um, has taken root, hasn't it? Has, it's put down roots in his imagination. Yeah. And so he's, uh, you know, by the time he's 16, he's, he's got his great passion. He's got his drawing. Um, he's got an absolute work ethic.
他坐过火车。你知道，所有那种世界，那种中西部世界，在某种程度上，呃，已经扎根了，不是吗？已经，它在他的想象中扎下了根。是的。所以他是，呃，你知道，到他 16 岁时，他，他有了他伟大的激情。他有了他的绘画。呃，他有绝对的职业道德。
I mean, Elias has absolutely kind of, you know, instilled him with that. And he's, you know, he's not an intellectual. He's not got a brilliant education, but he does have a very broad range of experiences, of memories, of dreams, basically. And then in September 1918, of course, the First World War has been raging. America has finally decided to join in the fun. He has one final adventure before adulthood claims him. He enlists for service with the Red Cross Ambulance Corps in France.
我的意思是，埃利亚斯绝对在某种程度上，你知道，向他灌输了这一点。而且他，你知道，他不是一个知识分子。他没有受过良好的教育，但他确实有非常广泛的经历、记忆、梦想，基本上。然后在 1918 年 9 月，当然，第一次世界大战一直在肆虐。美国终于决定加入这场乐趣。在成年之前，他有最后一次冒险。他报名参加了法国的红十字救护队。
And he's so young when he does say that he has to lie about his age on his. enlistment form and actually by the time that he and his valley volunteers reach France they have to go to La Havre because the port they're originally going to is full of bombed ships the war is actually over but you know he's going into a shattered France he sees scenes of devastation and death everywhere and undisputably this broadens his horizon massively as does his introduction to you know the architecture of Europe so he's stationed at one point near Versailles at another other point near the Louvre. He is billeted in a town called Neuf Chateau, which gives him a feel for the architecture of the old, you know, the old continent. And all the time, he's continuing to
当他报名时，他非常年轻，以至于他不得不在他的报名表上撒谎说他的年龄，实际上当他和他的志愿者到达法国时，他们不得不去勒阿弗尔，因为他们最初要去的港口挤满了被炸毁的船只，战争实际上已经结束了，但你知道，他进入了一个破碎的法国，他到处看到毁灭和死亡的场景，毫无疑问，这极大地拓宽了他的视野，他接触到，你知道，欧洲的建筑也是如此：所以他在某个时候驻扎在凡尔赛附近，在另一个时候驻扎在卢浮宫附近。他被安置在一个叫纽沙托的城镇，这让他对旧大陆的建筑有了一种感觉。而且一直以来，他都在继续
draw his cartoons and he's turning his hands to making props. And in a way, what he's doing there is he's improving reality. So with one of his friends, he pillages German helmets from local rubbish dumps. And he scuffs them up in dirt, he shoots bullet holes through them, and then he sells them as souvenirs from the front to tourists. So again, you can see elements of the Disney story. Definitely hint of Disneyland about that. So he goes back to Kansas City in the autumn of 1990, doesn't he? So he's not on the Western front for a very long time. But he's changed quite a lot. He's a much bigger, heavier person. Hello, Mom. I mean, you can imagine all that. He's taken up smoking and he smokes all his life, doesn't he? He has a terrible hacking cough.
画他的卡通，他开始动手制作道具。在某种程度上，他在那里所做的是他正在改善现实。所以他和他的一个朋友一起，从当地的垃圾堆里掠夺德国头盔。他在泥土里把它们弄脏，他用枪在上面打出弹孔，然后把它们作为来自前线的纪念品卖给游客。所以再次，你可以看到迪士尼故事的元素。绝对有迪士尼乐园的暗示。所以他在 1990 年秋天回到堪萨斯城，不是吗？所以他在西线的时间并不长。但他改变了很多。他是一个更大、更重的人。你好，妈妈。我的意思是，你可以想象所有这些。他开始抽烟，他一生都在抽烟，不是吗？他有可怕的咳嗽。
And he's much more self-confident. He's much more, you know, like so many people, he's gone to the war and he's come back a man. Yeah, he's not going to, he's not going to do what his father wants, which is to invest his career in jello. He's turning his back on the jello. He wants to follow his dreams. And obviously his dream is to draw cartoons. But Walt being Walt, a man who is never content with what he's got, the scope of this ambition becomes steadily ever more sweeping. So from, you know, just drawing static cartoons, he moves into animation, and then from animation into the production of animation, and from production into something, you know, I mean, the kind of the dream of an ambitious young man in 1920s
而且他更自信了。他更，你知道，像许多人一样，他去参加了战争，回来时成了一个男人。是的，他不会，他不会做他父亲想让他做的事，那就是把他的职业生涯投资在果冻上。他背弃了果冻。他想追随他的梦想。显然他的梦想是画卡通。但华特就是华特，一个从不满足于他所拥有的东西的人，这种野心的范围变得越来越广。所以从，你知道，仅仅画静态卡通，他转向了动画，然后从动画转向了动画的制作，从制作转向了某种，你知道，我的意思是，那种 1920 年代雄心勃勃的年轻人的梦想
America. He sets up a studio in Hollywood, and Walt had moved to Los Angeles in July 1923, partly because, obviously it's the center of the movie business, but partly also because his brother Roy, who had also been serving in the First World War and had actually seen action, he's there, and he is recuperating from TB in a hospital. And Roy, you know, he's the practical Disney as opposed to the visionary Disney, which is Walt. You know, they form a good team, and the studio that they set up is called the Disney Brothers studio. But I think there's never really any doubt where the center of gravity in that business is. And sure enough, by 1926, when they obtain their own studio lot on Hyperion
美国。他在好莱坞建立了一个工作室，华特于 1923 年 7 月搬到了洛杉矶，部分原因是因为，显然它是电影业的中心，但也部分是因为他的哥哥罗伊，他也参加了第一次世界大战，实际上见过战斗，他在那里，他正在医院里从肺结核中康复。而罗伊，你知道，他是务实的迪士尼，而不是有远见的迪士尼，也就是华特。你知道，他们组成了一个很好的团队，他们建立的工作室被称为迪士尼兄弟工作室。但我认为那个业务的重心从来没有真正怀疑过。果然，到 1926 年，当他们在洛杉矶的海佩里恩大道获得自己的工作室地块时，名字不再是迪士尼兄弟。现在是华特·迪士尼。关于好莱坞，好莱坞实际上只从 1910 年代中期开始。所以好莱坞本身，以及它所属的洛杉矶市，是一种伟大的实验，它是一种伟大的创新。而且那里的每个人都像华特一样来自其他地方。所以他是这群不可思议的人的一部分，他们，你知道，一直在创造新的东西。是的。而且我认为就像，你知道，洛杉矶从困境中崛起一样。
Avenue in Los Angeles, the name is no longer Disney Brothers. It is now Walt Disney. And just on Hollywood, Hollywood has only been going really since the mid-1910s. So Hollywood in itself, and indeed the city of Los Angeles, of which it's a part, is a kind of great experiment It's a great innovation. And everybody there has come from somewhere else, as Walt has. So he's part of this incredible generation of people who are, you know, creating something new all the time. Yeah. And I think that just as kind of, you know, Los Angeles has pulled itself up from its bootstraps.
华特也是如此。我的意思是，这就是使他成为一个实现美国梦的人的绝对典范。在整个 1920 年代，当他试图开辟道路时，你知道，他处于极度贫困中。他基本上靠烤豆子维持生活。有时他只能负担得起每周一次的淋浴。有时他看起来太瘦了，以至于，你知道，关心他的人担心他也得了肺结核，就像他的哥哥罗伊一样。所以他真的，你知道，在他职业生涯的早期，他生活在绝对的边缘。
So has Walt. I mean, that's what makes him an absolute paradigm of a guy living out the American dream. And throughout the 1920s, while he's trying to make his way, you know, he's in terrible poverty. He's basically subsisting on baked beans. There are times where he can only afford a weekly shower. And there are times where he looks so thin that, you know, people who are concerned about him worry that he's got TB as well, like his brother Roy. So he really, you know, he's living on the absolute edge in the early years of his career.
沃尔特也是如此。我的意思是，这正是他成为实现美国梦的绝对典范的原因。在整个20世纪20年代，当他试图闯出一条路时，他处于极度贫困之中。他基本上靠吃烤豆子维持生活。有时他一周只能洗一次澡。有时他看起来瘦骨嶙峋，以至于关心他的人担心他像他哥哥罗伊一样患上了肺结核。所以，在他职业生涯的早期，他确实生活在绝对的边缘。
But by in 1928, he's looking, you know, he's looking pretty established. So he's got his studio, which he's named after himself. And he's got growing numbers of animators who are working with him. And Disney has a real eye for brilliance in animation. He's married. So his wife, Lillian, married her in 1925. And he has a breakout cartoon character called Oswald the Lucky Rabbit. And Oswald is notable, both for very phallic ears, which are always kind of, they're kind of either slumping or very tumessent.
但到了1928年，他看起来已经相当稳固了。他有了以自己名字命名的工作室。他有越来越多的动画师与他合作。迪士尼对动画的卓越表现有着敏锐的眼光。他结婚了。他的妻子莉莲，他在1925年娶了她。他有一个爆红的卡通人物，叫幸运兔奥斯华。奥斯华以其非常像男性生殖器的耳朵而闻名，这些耳朵总是显得要么下垂，要么非常充血。
But also, Oswald, and this is a kind of prefiguring of what will happen with the three little pigs and Mickey Mouse, he's a kind of character. Yeah, he's got a personality. Yeah, he's not just a vehicle for visual gags. And this makes him, you know, this makes him a very, very popular figure. But there is an absolute disaster because the Disney brothers are very naive in business, even Roy. And they've got embroiled with an absolute shyster in New York. Charles Mintz. His name is Mr. Mintz.
但奥斯华也是——这预示了后来三只小猪和米老鼠的情况——他是一个有个性的角色。是的，他不仅仅是视觉噱头的载体。这使他成为了一个非常非常受欢迎的人物。但随后发生了一场绝对的灾难，因为迪士尼兄弟在商业上非常天真，即使是罗伊也是如此。他们被纽约的一个绝对骗子查尔斯·明茨卷入了纠纷。他的名字叫明茨先生。
Very sinister. And he, first of all, he poaches. the Disney animators, and then the absolute bombshell, he reveals they don't actually own the intellectual property rights to Oswald. Their distributor does. And Walt is massively in debt. He can't afford to keep them. So basically, Oswald, you know, this fallac-eared rabbit, he's lavished all his time, all the money, all his creativity on it. And now he finds he doesn't even own it. And it's an absolutely devastating moment that might have destroyed a lesser man. But it doesn't destroy Walt, and he vows two things.
非常阴险。首先，他挖走了迪士尼的动画师，然后是一个绝对的重磅炸弹，他透露他们实际上并不拥有奥斯华的知识产权。他们的发行商拥有。沃尔特背负着巨额债务。他负担不起留住他们的费用。所以基本上，奥斯华，这只长着像男性生殖器耳朵的兔子，他投入了所有的时间、所有的金钱、所有的创造力。现在他发现他甚至不拥有它。这是一个绝对毁灭性的时刻，可能会摧毁一个较弱的人。但这并没有摧毁沃尔特，他发誓要做两件事。
Firstly, he is never again going to lose control of his characters and his animations. They are always going to remain his. And secondly, he is determined to create a new character who will be bigger and better than Oswald had ever been. And this is Mickey Mouse. And actually, the birth of Mickey Mouse is one of those moments. It's a bit like JK Rolling on the train coming up with the idea of Harry Potter, because actually there's a train in this, isn't there? The claim is that Disney has gone to New York
首先，他再也不会失去对他的角色和动画的控制权。它们将永远属于他。其次，他决心创造一个比奥斯华曾经更伟大、更好的新角色。这就是米老鼠。事实上，米老鼠的诞生就是那样的时刻之一。这有点像J.K.罗琳在火车上想出哈利波特的点子，因为实际上这里面有一列火车，不是吗？说法是迪士尼去了纽约
and he's discovered that Mr. Mintz has stolen his animators and has stolen Oswald and he's getting the train back to Los Angeles, very long journey, and it's on the train that he comes up with the idea for Mickey Mouse and he sketches the character. But I think you're going to say, aren't you, Tom, that this isn't true?
他发现明茨先生偷走了他的动画师，偷走了奥斯华，他正坐火车回洛杉矶，这是一段非常漫长的旅程，正是在火车上，他想出了米老鼠的点子，并画出了这个角色。但我认为你要说，不是吗，汤姆，这不是真的？
I mean, Mickey Mouse, you could say, is the most famous movie star of the 20th century. And so it's not surprising that there are lots of myths that surround him, you know, a bit like King Arthur, who Disney will go on to make a film about. So, yeah, the story on the train, you know, that he's, or that he's been keeping mice as pets while he was in Kansas City. They're all kinds of stories. And I think it's impossible to know the truth about it. What does seem to be true is that initially, Walter had been planning to call this mouse he's got in his imagining Mortimer. And Lily and his wife
我的意思是，米老鼠可以说是20世纪最著名的电影明星。所以，围绕他的神话很多也就不足为奇了，你知道，有点像亚瑟王，迪士尼后来会为他拍一部电影。所以，是的，火车上的故事，或者他在堪萨斯城时一直把老鼠当作宠物养的故事。各种各样的故事都有。我认为不可能知道真相。看起来确实是真的，最初，沃尔特一直计划把他想象中的这只老鼠命名为莫蒂默。而他的妻子莉莲
says that Mortimer's too city. And so that's how they come up with. Mickey. I think Mortimer Mouse would have been even more successful. I don't know. I'm not sure about that. Whatever the truth, the fact is that Mickey has this breakout role in Steamboat Willie, the jazz singer of animation. And this sets Walt on one of the great creative spikes in the history of Hollywood, in fact, in the whole history of American culture. And key to this is the fact that Disney's development of animation, we've said how it's culturally innovative, how it's technologically innovative, it is also commercially innovative. And by the early 30s, Mickey is not just an American phenomenon, he is an international
说莫蒂默太土气了。所以他们想出了米奇这个名字。我认为莫蒂默鼠会更成功。我不知道。我不确定。不管真相如何，事实是米奇在《威利号汽船》中扮演了突破性的角色，这是动画界的《爵士歌手》。这使沃尔特走上了好莱坞历史上，实际上是整个美国文化史上最伟大的创意高峰之一。关键在于迪士尼对动画的发展，我们已经说过它是如何在文化上创新，如何在技术上创新，它在商业上也是创新的。到了30年代初，米奇不仅是一个美国现象，他还是一个国际
phenomenon. And for the first time, you start to get European intellectuals enthusing over Disney. So there's a German critic who describes Mickey as the preeminent personality of the screen today as the only artist who exemplifies in his work and technique, the pure form of talking films. And because of this reach, it's a perfect opportunity for Walt and Roy to put the shock of losing Oswald behind them because they're determined to exploit this Mickey Mania that's sweeping the world to the absolute full. And they do this by commercializing him on a scale that no one in American culture has ever witnessed before. And again, this is absolutely groundbreaking. And just on the Mickey Mania, I mean, Mickey comes really of age at the very end of the 1920s, beginning
现象。第一次，你开始看到欧洲知识分子对迪士尼赞不绝口。有一位德国评论家将米奇描述为当今银幕上最杰出的人物，是唯一一位在作品和技巧上体现了有声电影纯粹形式的艺术家。由于这种影响力，这对沃尔特和罗伊来说是一个绝佳的机会，可以将失去奥斯华的冲击抛在脑后，因为他们决心充分利用席卷全球的米奇狂热。他们通过前所未有的规模将他商业化，这在美国文化中是前所未见的。再一次，这是绝对开创性的。关于米奇狂热，我的意思是，米奇在20世纪20年代末、开始时真正成熟起来
in the 1930s. So in other words, the period when the Great Depression has seized America and Central Europe. And you can see why an a fun, escapist, cheeky, anti-authoritarian kind of character, which Mickey is at the beginning. And actually, the beginning, he's much more subversive and less conservative than he becomes. You can see why that would appeal to people, can you at a time when everything else is pretty grim. And also you can see why slapping him on, you know, just about every item that gets sold in a shop. would also work because by buying these things, you can invest in the kind of the spirit of defiance and jollity that Mickey represents. So the New York Times in the mid-30s, you know, is stunned by the
在20世纪30年代。换句话说，那是大萧条席卷美国和中欧的时期。你可以明白为什么一个有趣、逃避现实、厚脸皮、反权威的角色——米老鼠在最初就是这样的形象——会吸引人们，尤其是在一切都相当严峻的时候。你也能明白为什么把他印在商店里出售的几乎每件商品上也会奏效，因为通过购买这些东西，你可以投资于米老鼠所代表的那种反抗和欢乐精神。所以，30年代中期的《纽约时报》对
shoppers carry Mickey Mouse satchels and briefcases bursting with Mickey Mouse soap, candy, playing cards, bridge favors, hairbrushes, China wear alarm clots, hot water bottles, wrapped in Mickey Mouse paper tied with Mickey Mouse ribbon and paid for out of Mickey Mouse purses with savings hoarded in Mickey Mouse banks. So Disney is making money not just from the films themselves, but from the commercial opportunities. And again, this is an insight that Disney and indeed the whole, basically everyone will carry forward into the 21st century. So Walt starts becoming very rich for the first time. But it's interesting because he's not actually very interested in money for his own sake. No, he's not a luxurious kind of person. Is he not a big spending
购物者背着米老鼠书包，公文包里塞满了米老鼠肥皂、糖果、扑克牌、桥牌筹码、发刷、瓷器、闹钟、热水袋，用印有米老鼠图案的包装纸包裹，系着米老鼠丝带，用米老鼠钱包付款，并将积蓄存在米老鼠储蓄罐里。所以迪士尼不仅从电影本身赚钱，还从商业机会中获利。同样，这也是迪士尼，实际上是所有人，都将带入21世纪的洞察力。所以华特第一次变得非常富有。但有趣的是，他实际上并不太看重金钱本身。不，他不是那种追求奢华的人。他不是一个大手大脚
person? No. He wants money because he's a perfectionist and perfectionism, if you're being an animator, requires vast amounts of dollars. And so Walt uses all the loot that's been generated by Big Mouse, not just to produce the best animations ever seen, but to reinvent the very art of animation. So again, it's that sense of cultural and technological innovation going absolutely hand in hand. So we said, you know, he's been hiring the best animators in the business. is training those who aren't necessarily proficient. So it's like a kind of Renaissance workshop. He has the best artists available to him.
的人吗？不。他想要钱是因为他是完美主义者，而如果你是一名动画师，完美主义需要大量的资金。所以华特利用“大老鼠”创造的所有战利品，不仅是为了制作有史以来最好的动画，更是为了重塑动画这门艺术。所以，这再次体现了文化和技术创新齐头并进的理念。正如我们所说，他一直在聘请业内最好的动画师，并培训那些不一定精通的人。这就像一个文艺复兴时期的工作室。他拥有他能找到的最好的艺术家。
And the effect of this is that they can start drawing animations that have kind of color and depth and weight in a way that no one had ever done before. And this is what feeds into Snow White and the Seven Dwarves. But it's also why it comes to be called Disney's Folly. because obviously this is massive, massive capital investment. And the whole way in which Snow White is made, it's an enormous process of experimentation.
其效果是，他们开始绘制出具有色彩、深度和质感的动画，这是前所未有的。这就是《白雪公主与七个小矮人》的灵感来源。但这也是它被称为“迪士尼的愚蠢”的原因，因为这显然是巨大的资本投入。而且《白雪公主》的整个制作过程是一个巨大的实验过程。
So Walt's idea of storyboarding is to get all his animators together. He stands on a stage and he basically acts it out, you know, with all the characters, the wicked witch, the various dwarf Snow White herself. And it's so vivid in the memories of the animators that that basically is what the storyboard that they're then working from and the pressure on them to meet Walt's vision is unbelievably intense. But I think what makes it fun for them, what makes it exciting is the sense that they have complete license to experiment.
所以华特的分镜构思是把所有的动画师召集在一起。他站在舞台上，基本上把所有的角色都演了一遍，比如邪恶的皇后、各种小矮人，还有白雪公主本人。这在动画师的记忆中非常生动，基本上这就是他们随后工作的分镜脚本，而他们为了实现华特的愿景所承受的压力大得惊人。但我认为让他们感到有趣和兴奋的是，他们拥有完全的实验自由。
So they might work on a sequence for months and then Walt will say, no, let's not have that within it. And that might seem dispiriting, but they know that the next sequence might be something completely groundbreaking. They will sit there kind of throwing bricks through windows just so that they can see how glass smashes and draw it. I think the most amazing one, they find it very difficult to give Snow White the right kind of colour in her cheeks. She always kind of ends up looking a bit like a clown when they do it, you know, with the actual, on the actual plates. So every plate, a makeup artist, gives her a kind of little dusting of rouge on the cheeks. It's unbelievable attention to detail. And just the drawings alone, I mean, we're talking.
所以他们可能会为一个片段工作几个月，然后华特会说，不，不要把它放在里面。这看起来可能令人沮丧，但他们知道下一个片段可能是完全开创性的。他们会坐在那里，像往窗户里扔砖头一样，只是为了观察玻璃破碎的样子并把它画出来。我认为最神奇的一点是，他们发现很难给白雪公主的脸颊涂上合适的颜色。当他们在实际的赛璐珞片上操作时，她总是看起来有点像个小丑。所以每一张片子，化妆师都会给她的脸颊涂上一层淡淡的胭脂。这种对细节的关注令人难以置信。单单是画稿，我的意思是，我们谈论的是
talking about thousands upon thousands, just an unbelievable, a mind-boggling number of original drawings produced so for every frame of this film. I mean, on a scale that would have stupefied people even a few years earlier. But also, I mean, just for the listeners, if you go onto YouTube and you watch clips of 1930, mid-1930s films, obviously largely black and white films, and then you watch Snow White, the difference is mind-blowing. It's almost psychedelic in its impact, I think. And just one other thing to mention about the impact of the animations, that the human characters are stunning. They basically humans haven't been portrayed like that in animation before. And that again is kind of part of the process of what's
成千上万，简直是令人难以置信、令人瞠目结舌的原始画稿，每一帧电影都是如此。这种规模即使在几年前也会让人们感到震惊。但对于听众来说，如果你去YouTube观看1930年代中期的电影片段，显然主要是黑白电影，然后再看《白雪公主》，那种差异是令人震撼的。我认为它的视觉冲击力几乎是迷幻的。关于动画的影响，还有一点要提，那就是人类角色令人惊叹。在动画中，人类从未被这样描绘过。而这又是正在进行的过程的一部分。
being being worked out. And so it's not surprising that its impact is completely overwhelming for people. And Neil Gabler, I mean, he's very into the idea that what Disney is about is kind of creating self-contained world. So he writes about Snow White, whatever else the film does, this most deliberated upon movie in the history of film conveys a sense of control, a sense of a fully fabricated world. And you do get a sense of it as a kind of fairy tale that's existing in a state of suspended animation, something that's apart from the world. But I think also that on the animators, the people who made it, that imposed its own sense of pressure. So six months after the release of the film, Disney holds a delayed rap party.
所以它的影响对人们来说是完全压倒性的，这并不奇怪。尼尔·盖布勒非常推崇迪士尼创造了一个自给自足的世界这一理念。所以他在写《白雪公主》时说，无论这部电影还有什么其他作用，这部电影史上最深思熟虑的作品传达了一种控制感，一种完全虚构的世界感。你确实会感觉到它就像一个处于悬浮动画状态的童话故事，一个与世隔绝的东西。但我认为这对动画师，即制作它的人来说，也施加了他们自己的压力。所以电影上映六个月后，迪士尼举办了一场迟来的杀青派对。
The result is what has come to be known by historians of Disney as the snow-white orgy. It doesn't sound as bad as that might suggest. But I think by the standards of Walt, it's pretty wild. So the artist who've been in charge of animating the seven dwarfs, he's going for a pee from the third floor. He falls out of the window, ends up in a tree. which is a motif that will later reappear in the film Dumbo. I think what is very Studio 54 is somebody rides a horse into the house. Right. And that's quite good.
结果就是后来被迪士尼历史学家称为“白雪公主狂欢”的事件。听起来可能没那么糟糕。但我认为按照华特的标准，这相当疯狂。负责动画七个小矮人的艺术家，从三楼去小便。他从窗户掉了出去，掉进了一棵树里，这个主题后来在电影《小飞象》中再次出现。我认为非常像“54号工作室”风格的是，有人骑着马进了屋子。对，那挺有意思的。
And Walter arrives at the party, expecting that it's going to be family values and all of that. And he finds naked couples cavorting in the swimming pool. And one of the animators said, well, you know, something just snapped. We couldn't help it. And I guess that there you do have a kind of theme that again will run throughout a few future of Walt's career, which is every so often he gets wake-up calls, remind us to him
华特到达派对时，以为会是家庭价值观之类的东西。结果他发现赤身裸体的男女在游泳池里嬉戏。其中一位动画师说，好吧，你知道，有些东西突然断了。我们控制不住。我想这其中确实有一个主题，在华特未来的职业生涯中会一直贯穿，那就是他时不时会接到警钟，提醒他
that reality can't always be kept at bay, that sometimes events beyond his control will intrude. And of course, in the late 1930s, all kinds of things are menacing on the horizon. Yeah. So the strong clouds of war, no less, are looming overhead. And on that note, we'll take a break and we'll come back and find out what happens to Walt Disney. during and after the Second World War. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it.
现实并不总是能被拒之门外，有时他无法控制的事件会闯入。当然，在20世纪30年代末，各种各样的威胁都在地平线上显现。是的。战争的阴云正在头顶聚集。说到这里，我们休息一下，回来看看华特·迪士尼在二战期间和战后发生了什么。本集由Uber赞助。你知道那种在最需要的时候有人为你挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样，Uber知道这一点。
Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. It's showing up no matter what. Like for your long-distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. when it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Welcome back to The Rest is History. So Walt Disney has become immensely rich and immensely successful. Snow White has made his name not merely as an animator, but is a genuine cinematic. artist. And the question, Tom, is where does he go from here? What worlds are the left to conquer?
Uber不仅仅是乘车或送餐。它是无论如何都会为你挺身而出。就像为了你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会挺身而出。有志者，事竟成，我们在路上。Uber，我们在路上。立即下载应用程序。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。所以华特·迪士尼变得极其富有且极其成功。白雪公主不仅让他作为一名动画师成名，更让他成为了一位真正的电影艺术家。汤姆，问题是，他从这里去向何方？还有什么世界可以征服？
Well, what he does is he plows it back into the Walt Disney company because all he really wants the money for, as we said before, is to make films and specifically to push at the absolute limits of what can be achieved in animation. So to help him fulfill this ambition, he builds an entirely new studio complex in Burbank in Los Angeles. And this is dominated by, a three-story, state-of-the-art animation building, which Dominic, we've actually entered and toured, haven't we? Yeah. We went to explore Disney a few weeks ago.
好吧，他所做的是把钱重新投入到华特迪士尼公司，因为正如我们之前所说，他真正想要钱的原因是为了制作电影，特别是为了突破动画所能达到的绝对极限。为了帮助他实现这一抱负，他在洛杉矶伯班克建立了一个全新的工作室综合体。这里的主体是一座三层楼高的最先进的动画大楼，多米尼克，我们实际上进去参观过，不是吗？是的。几周前我们去探索了迪士尼。
And while this complex is being built, he's greenlit three new feature-length animated films. So Pinocchio is one of them. We've talked about that. The second one is Fantasia, which essentially is kind of MTV for classical music. It's Walt's attempt to go high-brow. And then there's Bambi.
在这个综合体建设的同时，他已经批准了三部新的长篇动画电影。其中之一是《木偶奇遇记》。我们谈过那个。第二部是《幻想曲》，本质上是古典音乐的MTV。这是华特尝试走高雅路线。然后是《小鹿斑比》。
and Bambi really is perhaps the biggest challenge of all because it requires his animators to draw anatomically correct animals which simultaneously have features that are human enough to make them appealing to children and this proves to be an enormous challenge it takes kind of years and years of experimentation to get there and all this experimentation basically rich though Snow White had a mate Walt it doesn't. doesn't stop him from burning through all the money he's made. And so it's not long before he has to start borrowing millions from the banks. And the banks lent him because they think, oh, it's all going to be fine.
《小鹿斑比》确实可能是最大的挑战，因为它要求他的动画师绘制解剖学上正确的动物，同时又要具备足够的人性特征，使它们对儿童具有吸引力。这被证明是一个巨大的挑战，需要多年的实验才能达到目标。所有这些实验，基本上，尽管《白雪公主》让华特赚了钱，但并没有阻止他烧掉他赚来的所有钱。所以没过多久，他就不得不开始向银行借数百万美元。银行借钱给他，因为他们认为，哦，一切都会好起来的。
You know, he's a genius. You know, these films will make enormous amounts of money. But obviously, that's a huge source of pressure. And on top of all this, his family life is, it's been marked both by a terrible tragedy and by new responsibility. So the tragedy, he's bought his parents a lovely state of the art. house in Los Angeles, and there his mother dies of carbon monoxide poisoning in the house that he, Walt Disney, had bought for her. And to make it worse, he had sent around Walt Disney
你知道，他是天才。你知道，这些电影会赚很多钱。但显然，这带来了巨大的压力。最重要的是，他的家庭生活既有可怕的悲剧，也有新的责任。悲剧是，他给父母在洛杉矶买了一栋漂亮的最先进的房子，而他的母亲就在他华特·迪士尼为她买的房子里死于一氧化碳中毒。更糟糕的是，他曾派华特·迪士尼的
engineers to make sure that, you know, the heating system was, was all fine. So he feels crippled with guilt about that. Also, by this point, he has two daughters, one of them adopted. And he's, he's a good father when he's around, but he's basically never around because he has just got so much on his plate. So a lot with these films, I mean, he's obviously the presiding genius of them. He has the overall vision. He's obviously a massive attention to detail, man. We'll see that in the next episode when we're talking about Disneyland.
工程师去确保供暖系统一切正常。所以他对此感到内疚。此外，到这个时候，他有两个女儿，其中一个是领养的。他在家的时候是个好父亲，但他基本上从不在家，因为他手头的事情太多了。所以对于这些电影，我的意思是，他显然是其中的主导天才。他有整体的愿景。他显然是一个非常注重细节的人。我们将在下一集谈论迪士尼乐园时看到这一点。
So, for example, with Fantasia, he's constantly arguing with the conductor about the music they're going to have. You know, he wants to be over every last detail. And he's also, he's still a great innovator, isn't he, technologically? I mean, he's still a man for a wheeze and a man for a fancy camera and a kind of a clever way of solving a problem, all of that kind of thing. Yeah, if he could make a massive camera that kind of stretches up to the ceiling and has loads of different plates and gizmos and things, he's all over that.
例如，在《幻想曲》中，他不断地与指挥争论他们要用的音乐。你知道，他想掌控每一个细节。而且他仍然是一位伟大的创新者，不是吗，在技术上？我的意思是，他仍然是一个充满奇思妙想的人，一个喜欢花哨摄像机和解决问题巧妙方法的人，诸如此类。是的，如果他能制造一台巨大的摄像机，一直延伸到天花板，并且有各种各样的盘子、小玩意儿之类的东西，他会非常热衷。
I think what he's not doing is any of the actual animation. He never actually, I think, really admits this. So part of the publicity is always pictures of him drawing Mickey. But he, you know, he hasn't been drawing Mickey for a very, very long time. And actually the people who did draw Mickey were often very offended by this, weren't they? Because he never quite... I mean, if I have a criticism, Walt Disney,
我认为他没有做的是任何实际的动画工作。我想他从来没有真正承认过这一点。所以宣传的一部分总是他画米老鼠的照片。但他，你知道，他已经很久很久没有画米老鼠了。实际上，那些真正画米老鼠的人经常对此感到非常冒犯，不是吗？因为他从来没有完全……我的意思是，如果我对华特·迪士尼有什么批评的话，
it is that he never was completely candid with the public about the fact that he didn't do the drawings. I mean, he does the voice. He does the voice for Mickey. Hi there. Yeah, but I mean, drawings are the thing that really... I mean, people when I think of Mickey Mouse, they think of the drawings first and not the sound, surely.
那就是他从未向公众完全坦诚他没有做这些画的事实。我的意思是，他配音。他为米老鼠配音。嗨，大家好。是的，但我的意思是，画作才是真正……我的意思是，当人们想到米老鼠时，他们首先想到的是画作，而不是声音，肯定是的。
Yeah, they do. I think that the films clearly reflect his vision. And as you say, he's always hands-on key aspects of the films that people always remember, they are basically down to him. So I guess the classic example would be in Bambi, probably one of the most traumatic moments in the whole history of cinema, when Bambi's mother gets killed.
是的，他们会。我认为这些电影清楚地反映了他的愿景。正如你所说，他总是亲力亲为关键方面，人们总是记得的电影片段，基本上都归功于他。所以我猜经典的例子是在《小鹿斑比》中，这可能是整个电影史上最令人痛苦的时刻之一，当斑比的母亲被杀时。
Huge debates about how this is to be done. It's Walt who says, well, we'll do it off screen, like a great tragedy. And I guess, you know, people have often said, well, what exactly is Walt's role? What exactly is the Disney studio? We've meant it's a bit like a renaissance studio, you know, studio where the grandmaster has all his,
关于如何处理这一幕有巨大的争论。是华特说，好吧，我们会在屏幕外处理它，就像一场伟大的悲剧。我想，你知道，人们经常说，华特到底扮演什么角色？迪士尼工作室到底是什么？我们说过它有点像文艺复兴时期的工作室，你知道，大师拥有他所有的
you know, people who are kind of working on different paintings and things like that. like that. It's also kind of like an Ivy League campus. And it's very like the early days of Apple, I think. It's a kind of mixture of all those things. Yeah, a team, a great team. Well, it is a great team to begin with, and it's a happy team, but it doesn't necessarily stay happy. So to look at the kind of the way in which the relationship of the animators to walk changes. Let's zoom in on one of those animators. He is a Jewish artist originally from Nebraska, Arthur Art Babbitt. Of course he's called Art Babbitt. I think this is a great thing about American
那些在不同画作上工作的人等等。它也有点像常春藤盟校的校园。我认为它非常像苹果公司的早期。它是所有这些东西的混合体。是的，一个团队，一个伟大的团队。好吧，起初它是一个伟大的团队，也是一个快乐的团队，但它并不一定一直快乐。为了看看动画师与华特的关系是如何变化的，让我们聚焦于其中一位动画师。他是一位来自内布拉斯加州的犹太艺术家，亚瑟·阿特·巴比特。当然他叫阿特·巴比特。我认为这是美国历史的一大特色，不是吗？
history, isn't it? The names are always perfect. So Art Babbitt, he joins the Disney studio in July 1932, so pretty much at the beginning. And he rises very rapidly through the ranks. He is fundamental to the look of Disney films. So he developed the character of Goofy, the dog. You will recall, Tom, that I asked the head of Disney layers, Bob Iger, to explain the relationship of Goofy and Pluto, a subject that has been perplexing Theo for years. Because Goofy's a dog and Pluto's a dog. Yeah, but one of them is a kind of anthropomorphic dog.
名字总是那么完美。所以阿特·巴比特，他在1932年7月加入迪士尼工作室，所以基本上是在刚开始的时候。他迅速晋升。他是迪士尼电影外观的基础。他开发了高飞狗这个角色。汤姆，你还记得我问过迪士尼高层鲍勃·艾格解释高飞和布鲁托的关系吗？这是一个困扰西奥多年的话题。因为高飞是一条狗，布鲁托也是一条狗。是的，但其中一个是拟人化的狗。
And the other is just a dog. I honestly think you're over-complicating things. I don't think I'm over-complicated. I haven't over-complicated it. I'm trying to get answers. I went to the top man and he didn't know. Well, maybe, I mean, maybe there's a slight degree of edge there, which I think is possibly reflective of Art Babbitt's personality.
而另一个只是一条狗。我真的认为你把事情复杂化了。我不认为我复杂化了。我没有复杂化。我是在寻求答案。我去找了最高层的人，但他不知道。好吧，也许，我的意思是，也许有一点点火药味，我认为这可能反映了阿特·巴比特的个性。
So it's notable that he is the person who is charged with animating the Wicked Queen in Snow White. You know, very difficult challenge. We said how hard it is for people, for animators at this point to bring human beings to life. He does it superbly, and then he moves on to do Geppetto in Pinocchio. So he's very important to the Disney Studios' cultural heft, but he is always rubbing Walt up the wrong way. So he's very loud, he's very obstreperous. he's also a massive womanizer and he absolutely appalls Walt by having an affair with the
所以值得注意的是，他是负责动画《白雪公主》中邪恶皇后的人。你知道，非常困难的挑战。我们说过，对于当时的动画师来说，让真人活灵活现是多么困难。他做得非常出色，然后他继续在《木偶奇遇记》中制作吉佩托。所以他对迪士尼工作室的文化分量非常重要，但他总是和华特发生冲突。所以他非常吵闹，非常喧闹。他也是一个巨大的花花公子，他通过与
woman who has served as the kind of human model for Snow White, who's a woman with the glorious name of Marjorie Belcher. Yeah, another brilliant American name. And obviously very offensive for Walt that basically he's, you know, he's shagging Snow White. Walt doesn't want that at all and would have sacked him for it had he not ended up marrying Marjorie Belcher. Okay, well, that's not so bad. I think Art Babbage is kind of man who resents this slightly Victorian degree of paternalism. I think he feels it's up to him who he hangs out with. And I think that reflects more broadly a sense that Walt, who initially had been one of the boys,
担任白雪公主真人模特的女性发生婚外情，让华特感到震惊，那个女人的名字叫玛乔丽·贝尔彻。是的，另一个出色的美国名字。显然对华特来说非常冒犯，基本上他是在，你知道，他是在和白雪公主上床。华特一点也不想要那样，如果他最终没有娶玛乔丽·贝尔彻，他早就把他解雇了。好吧，那还不算太糟。我认为阿特·巴比特是那种对这种略带维多利亚时代的家长式作风感到不满的人。我认为他觉得和谁交往是他自己的事。我认为这更广泛地反映了一种感觉，即最初是“自己人”之一的华特，
is increasingly becoming a boss. He's becoming kind of distant and imperious and autocratic. Listeners may remember, I mentioned that he came back from the Western Front with a hacking cough. the sound of that hacking cough and Walt's clicking heels coming down the passageway, it's capable of generating terror in animators. So Gabler again, there was a fear of Walt now, a fear that had always been latent in the sweaty palms and nervous silence at the story sessions, a fear of displeasing him.
正日益成为一个老板。他变得有点疏远、专横和独裁。听众可能记得，我提到过他从西线回来时带着剧烈的咳嗽。那种咳嗽声和华特走在走廊上的脚步声，足以在动画师心中产生恐惧。所以盖布勒再次提到，现在对华特有一种恐惧，一种在故事会议上汗流浃背和紧张沉默中一直潜伏的恐惧，一种害怕惹他不高兴的恐惧。
And Gabler quotes one animator who says that she would vomit after making a presentation to him. Yeah, he's slightly, by this point, he's definitely changed, hasn't he? the sort of boyish inventor has become much more autocratic and he remains more autocratic for the rest of his life. Yeah, well, it's interesting that the piece of music that kind of just states Fantasia is the Sorcerer's Apprentice, where Mickey is an apprentice who generates a labor-saving device in the form of a magical broomstick that ends up kind of overwhelming the sorcerer's palace.
盖布勒引用了一位动画师的话，说她在向他做完演示后会呕吐。是的，到这个时候他确实变了，不是吗？那个男孩气的发明家变得更加专横，并且在他余生中一直保持着这种专横。是的，有趣的是，那种构成了《幻想曲》的音乐是《魔法师的学徒》，米老鼠是一个学徒，他制造了一个劳动节省装置，形式是一把魔法扫帚，最终淹没了魔法师的宫殿。
It's interesting that Walt was interested in that story, the sense that, um, the sense that he's the sorcerer and the apprentices are creating chaos and turning his own creations against him. I mean, it may not have been conscious, but I think it must have been there subliminally because Art Babbitt is typical of the animators who are not prepared to be intimidated by him. And so he pushes for workers at Disney to unionize. And Walt is absolutely appalled by this and refuses point blank to allow any union into Disney. And I think this isn't initially out of political principle, although it will become so. because actually Disney's father
有趣的是华特对那个故事感兴趣，那种感觉，嗯，那种感觉他是魔法师，而学徒们正在制造混乱，并把他的创作反过来对付他。我的意思是，这可能不是有意识的，但我认为它一定是在潜意识里存在的，因为阿特·巴比特是那些不准备被他恐吓的动画师的典型代表。所以他推动迪士尼的工人成立工会。华特对此感到非常震惊，并断然拒绝允许任何工会进入迪士尼。我认为这最初不是出于政治原则，尽管后来会变成这样。因为实际上迪士尼的父亲
had been a self-proclaimed socialist. So to the degree that Disney had any political leanings, it was probably to the left. But I think the reason he's so appalled by it is that he thinks of the Disney studio as a kind of paradise. And if you're in paradise, you don't need unions.
曾是一位自称的社会主义者。所以如果说迪士尼有什么政治倾向的话，那可能是在左翼。但我认为他之所以如此震惊，是因为他认为迪士尼工作室是一个天堂。如果你在天堂里，你就不需要工会。
Yeah, we're all a happy family. What do you need? Imagine if Theo and Tabby wanted to unionize against us, Tom. Yeah. How would we feel? I think we would be correctly appalled and betrayed. And so that's how Disney feels when, on the 28th of May, 1941, several hundreds of his employees start a strike.
是的，我们都是一个快乐的家庭。你需要什么？汤姆，想象一下如果西奥和塔比想联合起来反对我们。是的。我们会怎么想？我认为我们会感到被正确地震惊和背叛。所以这就是迪士尼在1941年5月28日，当他的几百名员工开始罢工时的感受。
And so he, as we would be, is convinced that this must be caused by a Bolshevik conspiracy. And this guy who's the son of a left-wing socialist ends up, you know, reds under the bed, Bolsheviks everywhere. So on the morning of the strike, Walt very ostentatiously crosses the picket line. And Babbitt is on the picket line. he's got a loud speaker, and he yells out, Walt Disney, you should be ashamed of yourself. And Walt is furious. The crowd are cheering, Babbitt, not him. So Walt gets out of his car.
所以他，正如我们一样，确信这一定是布尔什维克阴谋造成的。这个左翼社会主义者的儿子最终变成了，你知道，床下的红军，到处都是布尔什维克。所以在罢工那天早上，华特非常显眼地穿过了纠察线。巴比特在纠察线上。他拿着扩音器，大喊：“华特·迪士尼，你应该为自己感到羞耻。”华特很愤怒。人群在为巴比特欢呼，而不是他。所以华特下了车。
He legs after Babbitt, who's running away, and he has to be physically restrained. And it's all very undignified, and it's not a good look at all for Walt. And the whole thing, the strike is an absolute public relations disaster for him. And after a couple of months, he recognizes that he's not going to win, that he's going to have to call in mediation. and he recognises that mediation is going to go against him and so rather than stay around for that humiliation
他追赶逃跑的巴比特，不得不被身体制止。这一切都非常不体面，对华特来说一点也不好看。整个罢工对他来说是一场绝对的公关灾难。几个月后，他意识到他不会赢，他将不得不要求调解。他意识到调解对他不利，所以与其留下来面对那种羞辱，
he decides to go off on a promotional tour of South America. That's Paul from Wintz I think you should have stayed to face the music but actually it's a transformative moment in the history of Walt and his company isn't it? Because after this point
他决定去南美进行一次宣传巡演。我想你应该留下来面对现实，但实际上这是华特和他公司历史上一个转折性的时刻，不是吗？因为从这一点之后，
the sort of happy family spirit never quite returns as it had before and Walt himself definitely changes doesn't he So he basically has the trajectory of Ronald Reagan. He's started out sort of vaguely centre left and he's going to end up becoming actually pretty right wing as a result, partly as a result of this strike.
那种快乐的家庭精神再也没有像以前那样恢复了，华特本人也确实变了，不是吗？所以他基本上有了罗纳德·里根的轨迹。他开始时有点模糊的中间偏左，结果他最终变得相当右翼，部分原因是这次罢工。
Yeah, well, Reagan retains his sunniness. I think in this period, Walt becomes quite gloomy, quite bitter, quite suspicious. And there's one of the animators, you know, he'd been there with him throughout the glory days. he said the esprit decor that made possible all the brilliant films of the 1930s was dead as a dodo so that's not looking good but there are other problems as well
是的，里根保持了他的阳光。我认为在这个时期，华特变得相当阴郁、相当痛苦、相当多疑。有一位动画师，你知道，他在整个辉煌时期都和他在一起。他说，使20世纪30年代所有辉煌电影成为可能的精神已经死得像渡渡鸟一样了。所以这看起来不太好，但还有其他问题
that are pressing on the Disney studio in the 40s Pinocchio, Fantasia, Bambi they're all huge critical hits people think they're stupefying but they all lose money and the main reason for this is that war has broken out in Europe
在40年代压迫着迪士尼工作室。《木偶奇遇记》、《幻想曲》、《小鹿斑比》，它们都是巨大的评论热门，人们认为它们令人震惊，但它们都赔钱了。主要原因是欧洲爆发了战争，
and so Disney has lost a vast part of its potential market. And this in turn by 1941 is directly impacting on Walt's ability to maintain his perfectionism. He just can't afford it. And it's suggestive that the only film in this period that makes a profit is Dumbo. So the story of a baby elephant with giant ears ends up flying. It's very stylistically paired back. And so that's the one that makes a profit. And we will be looking at Dumbo and all these great classics in much more detail in next week's bonus. So very exciting. Great.
所以迪士尼失去了其潜在市场的很大一部分。到1941年，这直接影响了华特维持其完美主义的能力。他负担不起。这表明这一时期唯一盈利的电影是《小飞象》。所以这个关于长着巨大耳朵的小象最终飞起来的故事。它的风格非常精简。所以那是盈利的一部。我们将在下周的奖励节目中更详细地探讨《小飞象》和所有这些伟大的经典作品。非常令人兴奋。太棒了。
So December 1941, Pearl Harbor, a date that will live in infamy, the United States enters the war. And presumably this is disastrous for the Disney Enterprise. In fact, it is disastrous, isn't it? Because Disney really, in his lifetime, the studio never really recovers from the shock of the Second World War. Yeah, so it's massively in debt to banks. Its audience has been cut off by the war. And the company just about stays afloat by making propaganda films for the US military. So, I mean, a particularly thrilling sounding one is four methods of flush riveting,
所以1941年12月，珍珠港事件，一个将永远活在耻辱中的日子，美国参战。据推测这对迪士尼企业是灾难性的。事实上，确实是灾难性的，不是吗？因为迪士尼在他的一生中，工作室从未真正从第二次世界大战的冲击中恢复过来。是的，所以它欠银行巨额债务。它的观众被战争切断了。公司勉强通过为美国军方制作宣传片来维持生存。所以，我的意思是，一个听起来特别令人兴奋的是《平头铆接的四种方法》，
which they haven't made a ride out of that at Disneyland. And it leaves Disney very precariously placed. So by 1944, the company owes the Bank of America $4 million, which at the time is a huge, amount. And it means that when the war ends, Disney emerged from it, the company can't afford to make animated films anymore. And even when in 1950, Roy Disney has kind of, you know, he's been paring back, he's been imposing austerity and all that kind of thing, can raise just enough money to make Cinderella. The animation of Cinderella is incredibly basic compared to, you know, the films that they've been making earlier. And I think that Walt himself basically loses interest
他们在迪士尼乐园里没有做过那个游乐设施。这让迪士尼处于非常危险的境地。到1944年，公司欠美国银行400万美元，这在当时是一笔巨款。这意味着当战争结束时，迪士尼从中走出来，公司再也负担不起制作动画电影了。即使在1950年，罗伊·迪士尼已经，你知道，他一直在削减开支，他一直在实施紧缩政策等等，也只能筹集到足够的钱来制作《灰姑娘》。与他们之前制作的电影相比，《灰姑娘》的动画非常基础。我认为华特本人基本上失去了兴趣
in making films. And although the company is busy cranking out live action films and then in due course, these rather paired back cartoons, he makes no great claims for them. He says that most of them are what, corn, he calls them. He means that that's a bad thing, right? Well, kind of, I mean, nutritious, but not kind of O'Crasine, I guess, would be the idea. And, you know, you compared him to Reagan, I mean, he does now seem to lots of people a pretty conservative figure. Definitely conservative in his politics. You know, he's hostile to unions.
在制作电影方面。虽然公司忙于制作真人电影，随后又制作了这些相当精简的卡通片，但他并没有对它们提出什么伟大的主张。他说大多数都是什么，玉米，他称它们为。他的意思是那是一件坏事，对吧？嗯，有点，我的意思是，有营养，但不是那种……我想，这大概就是那个意思。而且，你知道，你把他比作里根，我的意思是，他现在在很多人看来是一个相当保守的人物。在政治上绝对保守。你知道，他敌视工会。
He's all in with McCarthy, the idea that there are reds under the beds and all that. And I think also he is identified with a kind of cultural conservatism now. So whereas in the 30s, German intellectuals were all over him, now he's identified with apple pie and white picket fences and all of that. And one of the reasons for that, you know, you mentioned how Mickey in the 30s seemed a very subversive figure. Now, Mickey too seems very, very kind of dated, very pretty boring, really, compared to other kind of animated figures that are coming out at this time. So Tom and Jerry, you know, bang each other over the head with hammers and running into nails and all of that, or Bugs Bunny, that kind of thing. Yeah, I never thought we'd be doing Bugs Bunny on the rest of history, but here we are
他完全支持麦卡锡，认为床下有红军之类的想法。而且我认为他也现在被认定为一种文化保守主义。所以，虽然在30年代，德国知识分子对他趋之若鹜，但现在他被认定为苹果派和白色栅栏之类的东西。原因之一是，你知道，你提到米老鼠在30年代看起来是一个非常颠覆性的形象。现在，米老鼠看起来也非常非常过时，非常无聊，真的，与当时出现的其他动画形象相比。所以《猫和老鼠》，你知道，用锤子互相敲打，撞到钉子上之类的，或者《兔八哥》，那种东西。是的，我从没想过我们会在《历史的余味》中谈论《兔八哥》，但我们在这里了
because it's the Warner Brothers, isn't it? Warner Brothers Looney Tunes and Hannah Barbera and stuff like that. They're very subversive. They're very mad cap and zany. And by comparison, Disney's cartoons just feel a little bit stayed in the 50s. They feel bland, they're boring, they're kind of white bread. And again, to pursue the kind of the Elvis analogy, it's like Walt has been drafted into the army, or it's like, you know, Apple, Apple has that kind of incredibly fallow period between the first computers and then when they invent the iPod. So maybe it's written into the life cycle of iconic American cultural figures. I don't know. But important to emphasize, the company does not go under. Walt and Roy, between the.
因为那是华纳兄弟，不是吗？华纳兄弟的《乐一通》和汉纳-巴伯拉之类的东西。它们非常颠覆。它们非常疯狂和滑稽。相比之下，迪士尼的卡通片在50年代感觉有点陈旧。它们感觉平淡，无聊，它们有点像白面包。再次，为了追求那种猫王的类比，就像华特被征召入伍，或者就像，你知道，苹果公司在第一台电脑和他们发明iPod之间有那段极其荒废的时期。所以也许它写在标志性美国文化人物的生命周期里。我不知道。但重要的是要强调，公司没有倒闭。华特和罗伊，在……之间
and managed to keep it afloat. And Walt does continue to innovate. So one striking example of this in the post-war years is he basically invents the nature film. And Walt had always loved wildlife since he'd been a boy in Marcelline. And there's this very weird story that he always used to tell, that he'd been haunted by something that happened when he was a seven-year-old boy. He'd watched an owl fly and land on a tree in an orchard. And said, to quote, well, I don't know why, but I wanted to care.
设法让它维持下去。华特确实继续创新。战后几年，一个引人注目的例子是他基本上发明了自然电影。华特自从在马塞林当男孩时就一直热爱野生动物。有一个非常奇怪的故事，他总是讲，他被七岁时发生的一件事所困扰。他看着一只猫头鹰飞起来，落在果园的一棵树上。并说，引用，好吧，我不知道为什么，但我想要那只猫头鹰。
that owl. So I snuck up behind it and I grabbed it. Well, he immediately began to claw and fight and I threw him on the ground. In my excitement, I stomped on him and I killed the owl. That thing haunted me for a long time afterward. So he's got the voice of Ronald Reagan and the sentiments of the Fox murdering lawyer, Julian Maugham. Well, but Jolian Maugh, I think, has shown less contrition, hasn't he, over his murder of wildlife? So animals in the classic films from Snow White through to Dumbo are seen as friends of those who were persecuted, those who are menaced. So the woodland creatures in Snow White, the crows in Dumbo. And famously, notoriously, even if you're a hunter, in Bambi, man is portrayed as a creature so evil that the hunting lobby in America, they end up
所以我偷偷溜到它后面，抓住了它。好吧，它立刻开始抓挠和反抗，我把它扔在地上。在兴奋中，我踩在它身上，杀死了那只猫头鹰。那件事在那之后困扰了我很长一段时间。所以他有罗纳德·里根的声音和狐狸谋杀律师朱利安·莫汉的情感。好吧，但我认为朱利安·莫汉在谋杀野生动物方面表现出的悔意更少，不是吗？所以从《白雪公主》到《小飞象》的经典电影中的动物被视为那些受迫害、受威胁的人的朋友。所以《白雪公主》中的林地生物，《小飞象》中的乌鸦。而且著名地，臭名昭著地，即使你是一个猎人，在《小鹿斑比》中，人类被描绘成一个如此邪恶的生物，以至于美国的狩猎游说团体最终谴责它是对美国运动员提供的最大侮辱。所以我认为华特，你知道，他对动物的奉献显然是根深蒂固的。所以当1948年，他派电影制作人去阿拉斯加拍摄东西时。素材回来后，所有的人文关怀内容都极其无聊。但有很多海豹。所以华特说，好吧，我们就拍一部关于海豹的电影。所以它叫《海豹岛》。它赢得了奥斯卡奖。野生动物被大规模地拟人化了。所以就像在动画中一样，全是那种“嘿，小家伙”，
condemning it as the worst insult ever offered to American sportsmen. So I think Walt is, you know, his devotion to animals is clearly very deep rooted. And so when in 1948, he sent filmmakers to kind of shoot stuff in Alaska. And the footage comes back and all the kind of human interest stuff is incredibly boring. But there are loads of seals. And so Walt says, well, we'll just make a film about seals. And so it's called Seal Island. It wins an Oscar. The wildlife is massively anthropomorphised. So as in the animations, it's all that hell whole little fellow,
所有那种，“来吧。哦，妈妈生你的气了。”所有这些。我挺喜欢自然纪录片里的那种风格。我也喜欢。我总是记得我小时候看它们时的情景。我也挺喜欢它们的。我的意思是，显然它已经非常非常过时了。
all that kind of, come along. Oh, mommy's cross with you. All of that. I quite like that in the nature documentary. I did as well. I always remember them from when I watched them as a child. I quite like them too. I mean, obviously it's gone very, very out of fashion.
但是，毫无疑问，没有迪士尼，大卫·爱登堡等人会走上一条路径。我认为这是另一个例子，一个不那么引人注目的例子，说明迪士尼的影响力有多么深远。所以这是在文化层面。他在商业和技术层面也在创新。而且我认为非常有意义的是，他在电影高管中几乎是独一无二的，他将电视视为一个巨大的机会，而不是挑战，也不是威胁。是的。所以我们将在下一集谈论迪士尼乐园时深入探讨这一点。但基本上他签署了这个
But, you know, there's no question that without, Disney is bathing a path there that David Attenborough and so on will pick up on. And I think it's another example, much less hyper-hoping. profile one of how far-reaching Disney's influence is. So that's in the cultural dimension. He's still innovating on the kind of commercial and technological level as well. And I think it's really telling that he is pretty much unique among movie executives in seeing television, not as a challenge, not as a threat, but as a huge opportunity. Yeah. So we'll get into this a little bit in the next episode when we're talking about Disneyland. But basically he signs this
与ABC的协议，不是吗？ABC，今天仍然与迪士尼有关联。他在1954年签署了它，他们制作的第一个节目叫《迪士尼乐园》，这是一个巨大巨大的成功。我的意思是，它直接冲到了排行榜的顶端，并且在它播出的整个过程中一直保持在那里。是的，它由华特本人主持，到这个阶段他已经成为了“华特叔叔”，全国的叔叔，他出现在电视屏幕上，而且，你知道，非常里根，非常里根。他们有一个特别巨大的热门，那就是《戴维·克罗克特》，出生在
deal with ABC, doesn't he? ABC, which is still associated with Disney today. He signs it in 1954, and the first show they make is called Disneyland, and it's a massive, massive success. I mean, it goes right to the top of the charts, and it remains there for as long as it runs. Yeah, and it's presented by Walt himself, who by this stage has become Uncle Walt, uncle to the nation, and he appears on the television screens, and, you know, it's very Reagan, very Reagan. And they have one particularly massive hit, which is Davy Crockett, born on a
田纳西州的一座山上，自由之乡中最绿的州，所有这些。戴维·克罗克特戴着一顶带有长尾巴的浣熊皮帽。美国人喜欢这顶帽子，但我的意思是，我认为非美国人对它完全无动于衷，并感到困惑。但在美国，戴维·克罗克特为迪士尼提供了一个营销盛宴，你知道，这可以与米老鼠狂热相媲美，一度全国四分之一的人都在看它。所以这太棒了。这意味着自《白雪公主》上映以来，迪士尼第一次能够偿还债务并摆脱银行的纠缠。所以华特现在又富有了。而华特就是华特，他用这笔钱资助了一个新的痴迷，多米尼克，这是一个主题公园，后来被称为
mountain to up in Tennessee, greenest state in the land of the free, all of that. David Crockett wears a coon skin cap with a kind of long tail. Americans love this hat, but I mean, I think non-Americans are totally indifferent to it and bewildered by it. But in America, Davy Crockett provides Disney with a marketing bonanza that, you know, it's comparable to kind of Mickey mania and at one point a quarter of the of the entire country is watching it. And so this is great. It means that for the first time since the release of Snow White, Disney is able to pay off its debts and get the banks off its back. So Walt is now flush again. And Walt being Walt, he uses the money to fund a new obsession, which Dominic is a theme park, which will come to be
迪士尼乐园。是的。所以我们将在下一集讲述那个故事。而且我认为这是一个文化成就，我想说，和米老鼠与《白雪公主》一样重要和有影响力。当然，听众们，《历史的余味》俱乐部，我们自己的小，你知道，他们叫什么，米老鼠俱乐部成员。他们可以马上听到那一集，不是吗？他们绝对可以。但让我们继续电影的故事。让我们把电影的故事收尾。所以华特现在对火车和游乐设施非常感兴趣，是的，所有这些东西。
called Disneyland. Yes. So we will be telling the story of that in the next episode. And it It's a cultural achievement, I would argue, just as important and influential as Mickey Mouse and Snow White. And, of course, listeners to the rest is History Club, our very own little, you know, what do they call them, Mousketeers. They can hear that episode right away, aren't they? They absolutely can. But let's continue with the films. Let's just tie up the story of the films. So Walt is now terribly interested in trains and rides and, yeah, all of this stuff.
所以实际上，事实是他发现自己对电影有点厌倦了。他不像以前那样对它们感兴趣了。是的，我的意思是，他会痴迷于，你知道，每一帧的日子绝对一去不复返了。而且我认为随着60年代，你知道，反主流文化开始流行，60年代正在摇摆。迪士尼推出的动画，比如《101忠狗》或《石中剑》。这些已经明显成为了产品，不是像迪士尼曾经那样的“作者”的产品，而是大公司的产品。华特本人也认识到了这一点。
So actually, the truth is he finds that he's a bit bored of the films. He's not as interested in them as he once was. Yeah, I mean, absolutely the days when he would obsess over, you know, every frame, that's long gone. And I think that as the 60s, you know, counterculture is clicking in, 60s are swinging. The animations put out by Disney, so that would be 100 World Darmatians or Sword in the Stone. These have recognizably become the product, not of a kind of otter, as Disney had once been. but of a corporation. And Walt himself recognized that.
所以他在60年代说，我不再是华特·迪士尼了。华特·迪士尼是一个东西。它已经成长为一种完全不同的含义，而不仅仅是一个人。人们可能会想，好吧，他真的在乎吗？我认为不是很大，
So he said in the 60s, I'm not Walt Disney anymore. Walt Disney is a thing. It's grown to become a whole different meaning than just one man. And people may wonder, well, did he really care? I think not massively,
但有一点。所以也许这很有暗示性，但他于1966年12月15日死于肺癌。所以他自战争以来一直抽的所有那些香烟，你知道，
but a bit. And so perhaps it's suggested, but he dies of lung cancer on the 15th of December, 1966. So all those cigarettes he's been puffing on since the war, you know,
但有一点。所以也许有人暗示，但他于1966年12月15日死于肺癌。所以他自战争以来一直抽的那些香烟，你知道，
they basically catch up with him. But when he dies, he's immersed in an animated version of Roger Kipling's The Jungle Book, and he hasn't been as committed to an animation since Bambi, and it really shows, because actually the Jungle Book, I think, is brilliant, and it goes on to earn a fortune. So it suggests that perhaps had he lived, he might have returned to producing animations of the quality of those early films. But in the wake of his death, 1967, 1968, it's a kind of reverendable. It's a kind of revolutionary period in the United States. And his critics on the left, on the kind of
他们基本上追上了他。但当他去世时，他正沉浸在罗德亚德·吉卜林《丛林奇谭》的动画版制作中，自《小鹿斑比》以来，他从未对一部动画如此投入，这确实显而易见，因为我认为《丛林奇谭》非常出色，而且它后来赚了一大笔钱。这表明，如果他活着，他可能会回归制作那些早期电影质量的动画。但在他1967年、1968年去世后，这是一个值得尊敬的时期。这在美国是一个革命性的时期。他在左翼的批评者，在某种程度上
countercultural wing of American culture, identify him, I think, both as a symptom and a cause of very deep flaws in American culture. So it's commercialization. It's infantilization, the sense that Disney has infantilized the country and the fact that he's kind of degraded high culture. And this was something that Disney had been very paranoid. It's why he'd made Fantasia, but Fantasia had bombed, and so he'd kind of basically parked that. And the most venomous attack on Walt Disney as an individual comes in 1968, when the film historian Richard Schickle published a book called The Disney Version. And Shickle accused Disney of having created a world that was designed to shatter the two most
美国文化的反主流文化派别，我认为，将他视为美国文化深层缺陷的症状和原因。所以这是商业化。这是幼稚化，即迪士尼使国家幼稚化，以及他贬低了高雅文化的事实。这是迪士尼一直非常偏执的事情。这就是他制作《幻想曲》的原因，但《幻想曲》失败了，所以他基本上搁置了它。对华特·迪士尼个人的最恶毒攻击发生在1968年，当时电影历史学家理查德·希克尔出版了一本名为《迪士尼版本》的书。希克尔指责迪士尼创造了一个旨在粉碎两样东西的世界
valuable things about childhood, its secrets and its silences, thus forcing everyone to share the same formative dreams. And Shigle says that Disney had become a rallying point for the subliterates of our society. This is where American critics have got to in the late 60s. But of course, in Europe, critics have got there a lot earlier. So back in the 30s and 40s, we've said intellectuals in Europe love Disney. You've got Thomas Mann, Eisenstein, Dali. They all think he's brilliant.
童年最宝贵的东西，它的秘密和沉默，从而迫使每个人分享同样的成长梦想。希克尔说，迪士尼已经成为我们社会中半文盲的集结地。这就是美国评论家在60年代末所达到的地步。但当然，在欧洲，评论家们早就达到了这一点。所以回到30年代和40年代，我们说过欧洲的知识分子热爱迪士尼。你有托马斯·曼、爱森斯坦、达利。他们都认为他很天才。
But by the 50s, Disney has already come to seem to intellectuals and artists. outside America as the great exemplar of American cultural imperialism. And I'll quote one novelist. She's an Australian, but she lived in London so long that she's come to have a very British accent. She's called Pamela Travers, P.L. Travers. And in 1961, she described Disney as so coarse, so uncouth, so wrong in every way. And specifically, Dominic, she was responding to a script of her most famous novel,
但到了50年代，迪士尼在美国以外的知识分子和艺术家眼中，已经成为美国文化帝国主义的伟大典范。我引用一位小说家的话。她是澳大利亚人，但在伦敦住了很久，所以她有了非常地道的英国口音。她叫帕梅拉·特拉弗斯，P.L.特拉弗斯。1961年，她形容迪士尼如此粗俗、如此笨拙、在各方面都如此错误。多米尼克，具体来说，她是在回应她最著名小说的剧本，
which was the story of a strict, magical, practically perfect, one might say, a practically perfect nanny called Mary Poppins. And those who haven't read the novel, she gets blown in by a strong east wind. She arrives at number 17 Cherry Tree Lane in London. And there she becomes nanny to two children, Jane and Michael Banks, and in the novel by P.L. Travers, dark and wild and fantastical, and faintly menacing adventures ensue. And in California, Walt's two daughters had adored the book. It had come out in the 1940s. And Walt had been trying to buy the film rights to the book since 1943.
也就是关于一位严厉、神奇、几乎完美，人们可能会说，一位几乎完美的保姆玛丽·波平斯的故事。那些没读过小说的人，她是被一阵强劲的东风吹来的。她到达了伦敦樱桃树巷17号。在那里，她成为了简和迈克尔·班克斯两个孩子的保姆，在P.L.特拉弗斯的小说中，黑暗、狂野、奇幻，并伴随着隐约的威胁性冒险。在加利福尼亚，华特的两个女儿非常喜欢这本书。它出版于20世纪40年代。华特自1943年以来一直试图购买这本书的电影版权。
But Pamela Travis held out, didn't she? Because she basically, you know, she believed, as lots of more high-brow people did, that Disney meant dumbing down, and it meant commercialism and sentimentality and so on. But basically because she needed the cash. In 1961, she decides, well, maybe I will sell Mary Poppins to Disney. But there's still a bit of towing and throwing, isn't there? Which is what is captured in the film. What's it called?
但帕梅拉·特拉弗斯坚持住了，不是吗？因为她基本上，你知道，她相信，正如许多更高级知识分子所做的那样，迪士尼意味着低俗化，意味着商业主义、感伤主义等等。但基本上是因为她需要钱。1961年，她决定，好吧，也许我会把《玛丽·波平斯》卖给迪士尼。但仍然有一些拉锯战，不是吗？这就是电影中捕捉到的内容。它叫什么名字？
Saving Mr. Banks. Saving Mr. Banks. So that's Tom Hanks as Disney and Emma Thompson as P.L. Travers. It's a very good film, quite funny, moving. But the whole, the kind of the history behind it, the actual story, is brilliantly explicated in a new book that's actually out next week by Todd James P. called Making Mary Poppins. And he goes into some detail about exactly why P.L. Travers hated the script.
《大梦想家》。《大梦想家》。所以那是汤姆·汉克斯饰演迪士尼，艾玛·汤普森饰演P.L.特拉弗斯。这是一部非常好的电影，很有趣，很感人。但整个背景历史，实际的故事，在托德·詹姆斯·P.下周即将出版的新书《制作玛丽·波平斯》中得到了精彩的阐述。他详细介绍了P.L.特拉弗斯为何讨厌这个剧本。
So, as you suggested, to quote Pierce, she believed that Disney had replaced elements of truth and insight central to her books with a saccharine sentimentality. She loathed the way in which the script had Americanized what Travis saw as absolutely an English story, all kinds of social solacons in it. So the script describes Mr. and Mrs. Banks as hiring a nanny rather than employing one, unforgivable. Oh, that's shocking. And also, also it showed the servants in the bank's household speaking slang, which Travis pointed out to the scriptwriters, unacceptable for hired help in England. Hired help?
所以，正如你所建议的，引用皮尔斯的话，她认为迪士尼用一种甜腻的感伤取代了她书中核心的真理和洞察力。她厌恶剧本将特拉弗斯视为绝对的英国故事美国化的方式，里面有各种各样的社会暗示。所以剧本描述班克斯先生和太太雇佣了一位保姆，而不是聘请了一位，不可原谅。哦，那太令人震惊了。而且，而且它还显示班克斯家里的仆人说俚语，特拉弗斯向编剧指出，这对于英国的雇佣帮工来说是不可接受的。雇佣帮工？
Surely employed help. She didn't want any songs. She didn't want any animated sequences. And I think her real worry was that she knew from previous Disney films that they end up obliterating the literary works that they were based on. It's just not, I mean, who reads Mary Poppins now? Nobody. Absolutely. And so this is exactly, you know, as Pierce says, at some point in the future, the public might think of Mary Poppins more as a Disney character than as a character she herself had created in her books. And as you say, Dominic, she is absolutely right about that. But I think as Pierce's book demonstrates, all the aspects of the script she disliked were precisely the ones that would make Mary Poppins an absolutely massive smash. And it becomes the most critically lauded, the most commercially successful Disney film.
肯定是聘请的帮工。她不想要任何歌曲。她不想要任何动画片段。我认为她真正的担心是，她从之前的迪士尼电影中知道，它们最终会抹杀它们所基于的文学作品。我的意思是，现在谁还读《玛丽·波平斯》？没人。绝对没有。所以这正是，你知道，正如皮尔斯所说，在未来的某个时候，公众可能会认为玛丽·波平斯更多是一个迪士尼角色，而不是她自己在书中创造的角色。正如你所说，多米尼克，她对此绝对正确。但我认为正如皮尔斯的书所证明的那样，她不喜欢的剧本的所有方面恰恰是使《玛丽·波平斯》取得巨大成功的因素。它成为自《白雪公主》以来，评论界赞誉最高、商业上最成功的迪士尼电影。
since Snow White. And it is also, I think, the film that is most pointedly and most movingly about Walt Disney himself. Because at the heart of the plot, the script that has been adapted from P.L. Travis's book and which he's so sniffy about is the emotional journey that is taken by the father of Jane and Michael Banks, Mr. Banks. And Mr. Banks in Mary Poppins is a man who spends all his time in the office, so therefore neglecting his children, who, you know, he works in a bank, but he is essentially the slave of a bank. And he feels the burden of the bank on his back so profoundly that he neglects to perform simple acts of kindness, such as, for instance, buying food for the birds. And Mr. Banks in the film even has a little pencil moustache,
而且我认为，这也是最尖锐、最感人地关于华特·迪士尼本人的电影。因为在情节的核心，那个改编自P.L.特拉弗斯书的剧本，也就是他如此挑剔的剧本，是简和迈克尔·班克斯的父亲班克斯先生所经历的情感旅程。在《玛丽·波平斯》中，班克斯先生是一个整天待在办公室的人，因此忽视了他的孩子，你知道，他在银行工作，但他本质上是银行的奴隶。他感到银行的重担压在背上，以至于他忽略了进行简单的善举，例如，给鸟儿买食物。电影中的班克斯先生甚至留着一撇小胡子，
exactly like Disney does. He's David Tomlinson, isn't he? Very good British character actor. excellent. But yeah, there is definite Walt Disney quality to him, isn't that? Yeah, Travis hates it because it's basically become something that she doesn't recognize, you know, that all the kind of the sadness and the darkness she thinks has gone
和迪士尼一模一样。他是大卫·汤姆林森，对吧？非常好的英国性格演员。太棒了。但确实，他身上有一种明确的华特·迪士尼特质，不是吗？是的，特拉弗斯讨厌它，因为它基本上变成了一种她不认识的东西，你知道，她认为所有的那种悲伤和黑暗都消失了
and that it's basically become a kind of story about a family discovering its heart. As she sees it as schmaltzy and sentimental. But I think that to anyone who's familiar with Walt's life, and my sense of Mary Poppins as a great film was massively and by kind of reading up about Disney's life, Walt Disney's life, you know, his
它基本上变成了一个关于家庭发现其内心的故事。在她看来，这是矫揉造作和感伤的。但我认为，对于任何熟悉华特生活的人来说，我对《玛丽·波平斯》作为一部伟大电影的感觉，在阅读了迪士尼的生活，华特·迪士尼的生活后，得到了极大的增强，你知道，他的
obsessional drive, his neglect of his family, his, you know, his lifelong struggle with banks and debt and so on. The kind of the redemption that Mr. Banks has at the end of Mary Poppins, because Mary Poppins herself essentially succeeds in restoring to him joy and kindness and love for his children. Actually, I don't. find it sentimental. I find it very moving. I think that the kind of the ending of Mary Poppins, Disney has won that ending. And so at the end of Mary Poppins, Mr. Banks leads his children out into the park and he's made a kite. And as he goes, he sings, oh, oh, let's go fly a kite up to the highest height. Let's go fly a kite and send it soaring up through the highest height. Let's go fly a kite
执着的动力，他对家庭的忽视，他，你知道，他与银行和债务的终身斗争等等。班克斯先生在《玛丽·波平斯》结尾处的救赎，因为玛丽·波平斯本人本质上成功地恢复了他对孩子的快乐、善良和爱。其实，我不觉得它感伤。我觉得它非常感人。我认为《玛丽·波平斯》的结局，迪士尼赢得了那个结局。所以在《玛丽·波平斯》的结尾，班克斯先生带着他的孩子们来到公园，他做了一个风筝。当他走的时候，他唱着，哦，哦，让我们去放风筝，飞到最高处。让我们去放风筝，让它翱翔在最高处。让我们去放风筝
and send it soaring up through the atmosphere up where the air is here oh let's go fly a kite and with that Dominic her job done Mary Poppins can depart on the wind that has just changed well that was really lovely I'm sure everybody enjoyed that so the story of Disney is not yet over, because in the next episode we'll be looking at perhaps his most enduring creation, which is Disneyland, and we'll be digging into the prehistory of theme parks and indeed of rides. Where do they come from? Were people really going on rides in the 18th century?
让它翱翔在天空中，飞到空气所在的地方，哦，让我们去放风筝。多米尼克，随着她的工作完成，玛丽·波平斯可以乘着刚刚改变的风离开了。嗯，那真的很可爱，我相信每个人都喜欢。所以迪士尼的故事还没有结束，因为在下一集中，我们将看看他也许最持久的创造，那就是迪士尼乐园，我们将深入挖掘主题公园甚至游乐设施的史前史。它们来自哪里？人们在18世纪真的在玩游乐设施吗？
The answer is that they were. But also, we have a very special bonus for our rest is history club members, because Tom will be looking in great detail at Disney at war and the story behind some of those great films of the Golden Age, Snow White, Pinocchio. Tokyo, Fantasia, Dumbo and Bambi. So a pretty exciting prospect, if you like Disney, which we do. And Dominic also, we have some extra content which will be available for everyone coming out on Friday. And so, on that suitably commercial note, for now, bye-bye.
答案是他们确实在玩。而且，我们为我们的“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员准备了一个非常特别的奖励，因为汤姆将非常详细地研究战争中的迪士尼，以及那些黄金时代伟大电影背后的故事，如《白雪公主》、《木偶奇遇记》、《幻想曲》、《小飞象》和《小鹿斑比》。所以，如果你喜欢迪士尼，这是一个非常令人兴奋的前景，我们确实喜欢。多米尼克，我们还有一些额外的内容，将在周五提供给所有人。所以，以这种恰当的商业基调，现在，再见。
Bye-bye. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。